this is Jocko podcast number 179 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening so the spear
Danes in days gone by and the kings who
ruled them had courage and greatness we
have heard of those princes heroic
campaigns there was shield sheafson
scourge of many tribes a wrecker of mead
benches rampaging among foes this terror
of the hall troops had come far a
foundling to start with he would
flourish later on as his powers waxed
and his Worth was proved in the end each
clan on outlying coasts beyond the whale
road had to yield to him and begin to
pay tribute that was one good King boom
opening with a little bit of Beowulf and
that is the opening of Beowulf
translated by Seamus Haney and what I
noticed is even back in the day in the
opening of the the original Old English
poem the first one written what are they
talking about they're talking about war
and they're talking about leadership and
you can hear in the beginning he was a
little bit of a weak leader he was a
foundling to start with but he would
flourish later on became a good king and
that's what happens you learn you get
better and that is why we talk about war
and leadership here and speaking of war
and leadership back for a third time my
brother Jason Gardner retired Master
Chief who I've known since I got into
the teams in the early 90s he's been on
the podcast before so if you haven't
listened to one
t7 and 168 go listen to those first
there's a lot of ground covered in those
podcasts and I told him to listen in and
listen to him again and see which what
we missed so he could go back and that's
we're gonna do now cover some more
ground hit some of that stuff that we
missed so welcome back Jason thank you
Jack there's I when I first got that
translation which was actually when I
was in college and it starts off with so
I just said oh my god this is totally
legit so I start thinking of a soul lot
now when I write I knew that I'd do that
so yeah welcome back how's retirement
treating you good to go I was gonna say
awesome but I'd be awesome absolutely to
death in the last two podcasts so I want
to try and ban it from life did your
Southern California childhood creep out
with some awesome yes everything is
awesome yep yeah
so you gotta watch out for that so what
do we miss I know we missed something
from your youth what were you talking
about the best the best show you ever
saw the best punk rock show you ever saw
yeah there was one that and this is
before I could even drive buddy of mine
Justin Hawkins and Alicia went up to
this this gig at Cypress College and it
was di plain rap the Dickies the Vandals
the Circle Jerks and there might have
been one other band for seven dollars in
free sale so we got presale tickets we
went up there got in there was probably
about 500 people outside who weren't
able to get in because it sold out so
they just went ahead and knocked the
doors down and all flooded in so what
that meant was nobody got searched
coming in for security and people had
crazy stuff like firecrackers it was way
overcrowded for you know what the safe
safe amount for the building was so when
you went up by where the
Wars were the security guys that just
put pushed all these tables and chairs
and we're sitting on him up against the
doors to keep anybody else from coming
in and the the show is just unreal there
were three mosh pits and then when the
Circle Jerks came out they opened up
with wild on the streets the whole floor
exploded one the pit started floating
crashed into another pit people were
thrown bricks of firecrackers around it
was mass pandemonium was so much and so
you were like 14 or 15 15 years old yeah
my mom had dropped me off at the dropped
us off there that's awesome mom oh yeah
she's got scared away man that's squared
away yeah cuz a lot of times you pay for
your parents if parents trying to shield
their kids from that or they won't let
him go then you would have just snuck
out they would have never known and were
yep and gotten in trouble and I want
rebelled against it right yeah yeah
that's what happens if you if you if
your parents trying to control you too
much it's kind of like with with any
person right you try to control them too
much then they get out of control they
rebel against you right discussion I
think I was having the other day with
your daughter about people just trying
to box people in it's another example of
this over centralized command and this
it is too much too much stuff like that
they're just gonna go the other way
I was actually touched I was talking
about this with a leader in a company
and I was explaining cuz you like for
sure money drives people compensation
drives people but ability to choose your
fate or have some influence over your
fate is is a also very powerful
motivator and incentive for people to
follow so when you have a look like if
you have one job where you make more
money but you don't have any freedom and
you don't have any control over your own
fate versus a job when you get paid less
money but you have really a lot of
autonomy most people will go with the
autonomy there are rare people that
don't want any autonomy they just pretty
much want to get told hey give me my
paycheck I'll do whatever you tell me to
do and that's fine
and that they're not into their job but
but a lot of people the more autonomy
you give them the more into it they are
the more they enjoy what they're doing
whereas if you're just micromanaging
or centralized command scenario they're
not into it and that's a problem and
that the first person you gave the
example and probably exercises no
initiative whatsoever exactly exactly
there you know what you have to address
that you have to address that when
working with companies that there are
people that they just want to get their
paycheck they're gonna punch the clock
at 4:59 every day and that's the way it
is they don't want to get promoted
they're fine with that and so you've got
to know and you'll answer those people
always is oh if you're leading someone
like that okay you know what you've got
get the most out of them take good care
of them and they'll do their job well
and you know you can count on them for
that so that's fine there's nothing
wrong with that it just that somebody
that does have higher goals or different
goals I guess where they want to break
out of that then you got to give them
the opportunity and those people if you
box them in they're gonna rebel against
you gotta look out you don't be like
Jason Gardner aged 15 with a mohawk Jack
Jack so I don't one of the other things
that you wanted to talk about a little
bit was with Scotty words that's right
you know and just coming after right
after Memorial Day it's really fitting
to discuss him Scotty was a good friend
of mine just a fantastic team guy
he did he did six years in the teams and
then separated in 2005 and he did what a
lot of guys did at the time was he
started contracting overseas because he
wanted to be at that point of friction
and for Scotty I don't think he was ever
ever happier than then when he was at
that point of friction so he did a bunch
of contracting he wound up getting hired
by the Defense Intelligence Agency as a
as a GS position a full-time position
and then January this last January he
was killed by a suicide bomber when he
was out operating in Syria and I
remember when I got the text message we
were all in a group text that that he
passed and I just man it it kind of
floored me for a second but then you
know it's like Scotty died doing what he
loved
and he was just such he was a maniac in
the best sense of the word
like the hardest I've ever laughed in my
life is with him and and most people
will tell you that anytime they've had a
good belly laugh or something he you
know was with Scotty and he had that
kind of contagious smile where you look
at pictures and Seth is a lot like this
when I look at Seth's pictures he's got
that smile that just has that special
thing about it that automatically makes
you you smile then you know you are not
ever going to be the voice of reason and
you are always going to be a good time
and your good friend and so while
there's there's remorse that he's not
here anymore
I'm so fired up that I got to spend the
time with him that I did and so anyway I
mean there you really have it he passed
he's from st. Louis so they had a big
funeral form there and it was at this
Catholic cathedral there had to be a
thousand people inside that Cathedral
and it was raining the day they had it
so the the funeral procession from the
Cathedral to the military cemetery where
they buried him had to be like at least
30 miles every single overpass on the
freeway on the drive there had fire
trucks and first responders out on it
the freeway they shut the freeway down
every exit was stopped by police
officers which is which is pretty pretty
dang cool that's also then when we got
off the freeway and we were driving on
the surface streets people the people of
st. Louis just pulled their cars over
and they were standing at attention out
in the rain
and so it's moving when someone in
uniform does that but you almost kind of
expect that out of them but when you see
like a 30 year old mother of two and or
two like eight year old kid and seven
year old kid
standing at attention with their hands
in the heart over their hearts in the
rain and it was a cold rain as as he
went by it's just it's an it's an
amazing and humbling experience to to
see that kind of love and respect by the
people of this country and the people of
st. Louis yeah that's that's awesome I
well I was at with with Chris Kyle's
procession going down to where he was
buried and that was a long drive I want
to say it was a few hours and the entire
thing and again it was raining same
thing we're in Texas but it's raining
and sure enough I mean there was people
were lying the entire way and I was
riding with one other guy and it was
just and we were in this massive there
was a massive procession of people but
it was just I remember sitting there for
a long time it's just the windshield
wipers just going back and forth we're
not talking because there's nothing to
say you can't you can't put words to
that you know you can't put words to
thousands of people standing out in the
rain with their hands on their hearts
just every bridge fire trucks flags hung
up from the ladders extended yeah this
the same same type of feeling that that
I had one when I was doing that and it
definitely makes you realize that
regardless of all the what do they say
these days that America is division all
this division that everyone talks about
there's plenty of people that that
understand what it what it takes to keep
this country free for sure absolutely I
feel like it's such a small and maybe
vocal minority that's out there and I
don't think it's on a whole I think
we're we're on even though a lot of us
have our differences and I think we're
figuring out how to discuss politics
just by looking at how people discuss
stuff on social media and people we're
dialing it in and they're they're able
to have realistic discussions with each
other without getting too hateful
and there are some people that are still
figuring that out yeah for sure I'll say
two things about that I was on I was on
Ben Shapiro's podcast yeah and you know
Ben was like and Ben's a real nice guy
he's you know very nice to me and you
know and all that and he's you know he's
what's pretty cool about him is he's
like got this running list of everything
that he said that's stupid
or wrong or whatever his Mia culpa list
but anyways yes we were having this
conversation he was hinting at the fact
of this massive division and you know
these massive right against the massive
left and and you know I said listen man
I travel the whole country all the time
I work with construction companies with
finance companies with now you do to
insurance companies I mean we meet
people from every different industry I
said these people aren't on the extreme
right they're not on the extreme left
their common sense they're Americans and
I said you Ben you're you're like here
at at Ground Zero for political like
mayhem and so what do you expect to see
like you're you're the you're the
lightning rod for a lot of this stuff
and so that's what you hear has it
normal America it didn't really like
that you know it's just not it's just
not I'm out there all the time you're
out there all the time now you know you
see it no one's coming up to you saying
you know with with some extreme views
are there small number of people sure on
both sides yes absolutely but in general
people are realizing oh well that's not
a bad point and then I was on Brian
compliments podcast and we were talking
about the same thing and what's
interesting is you know ben shapiro is
pretty pretty fond of him right and and
brian koppelman is pretty far on the
left and me i think they're both really
nice guys that are super cool and but
what i said to him was you know what
you're saying what I believe is leading
to the attitude kind of shifting is
basically this if you're not humble and
you think you know everything then why
should I listen to anything that you say
you know why should if I'm on the far
left why should I listen to anything I
know everything and everyone
right is wrong if I'm on the far right
well I should I listen to anyone that
anyone said anything with anyone saying
on the other side I know everything if
you're humble and you say you know what
I've got some ideas but I'm probably not
a hundred percent right you know maybe
I'm only 98 percent right no if you just
look at other people and say oh you know
what I probably don't have the full
solution for this maybe I should listen
to other people's opinions and try and
try and come up with a more broad-based
idea than just what I think so I think
people are starting to realize if you
take one extreme view and you don't
listen anyone else then you're wrong and
so I think people are becoming a little
bit more balanced I certainly hope I
yeah and and I know that that I've got
some really really close friends that
are on both ends of the spectrum and
when I sit down them with them and have
a logical conversation with them I find
out that our values yeah hard this
they're the same yeah and really it's
just a lot of misrepresentation and and
some unfortunate semantics sometimes
that you know I've drawn us to different
directions or put us on different sides
and you know that's it speaking of the
left hand and the right hand yeah
this is you've got to tell the story
about and this is this is a good
revealing story about I've alluded to
oftentimes the dark sense of humor in
the teams and there's a dark sense of
humor in the military you kind of have
to have a dark sense of humor and I
think did you see the movie range 15 no
oh okay it's it's about it's just a
crazy movie that Tim Kennedy and and and
Matt best and the black rifle coffee
company yeah all those guys they throw
the keys to the girl yeah yeah it's just
it's just every horrible dark joke that
you could make they make and I don't
know how well it did or whatever it did
good enough it did good enough I'm sure
defended a lot of people I'm sure
offended a lot of people
yeah but they did it so good for good on
them but you know you talk about that
that kind of dark sense of humor and I
think this story which you like called
me I don't know whatever it was six
months ago or whatever you called I
gotta tell you a story which whenever
you call me and tell me that I get super
excited I tell my kids to leave the room
and I like put you on speakerphone and I
put you on speakerphone and then I'm
mute so I don't bus I'm gonna interrupt
you by laughing so hard because whenever
you call me tell me got a good stir and
I'm thinking here we go so yeah tell us
about the hand so and and I talked to
Erin Kendall this morning to make sure I
got the details correct so Erin Kendall
is a seal that was working at the
training detachment when I was the
command master chief there and he is on
a hunting trip out in Texas like a
foundation supported hunting trip and
he's driving one of those side-by-sides
out to where he's gonna hunt like
side-by-side ATV yeah like an ATV drive
like one of those razors right no and it
rolls and it's mat the roll bar smashes
his left arm so he makes a tourniquet
out of his belt and walks like a mile
back to the range house and then they
call they try to call LifeFlight life
like can't come out it's too foggy they
get an ambulance comes and gets them
they start driving them up towards to a
hospital at San Antonio now he's in the
hospital they wind up having to amputate
his left hand in the hospital in this
first hospital why is that Oh cuz it was
just completely was so smashed
yeah his forearm was just smashed it was
done he was losing so much blood through
there and they they they ended up like
they kind of had to fight to save the
amputation below his elbow because they
were worried that because later on in
surgeries they're taking more and more
so there were a couple other team guys
that were there and other team guys flew
in to help out and they're staying at
this hotel right outside the hospital
where he's at so they take him from
where he was they take him to this
hospital he's at this hospital and at
that hospital they have to amputate his
hand
so he's bedside talking with the other
with some other seals and they're the
surgeon who amputate his hand is in
there checking on him and they asked the
surgeon hey do you guys still have his
hand and the surgeon says yeah I think
so
I don't you know we haven't destroyed
and and they asked him what are you
gonna do with it and it goes well you
know I guess we they destroy it or
whatever and so Aaron asks what can I
have my hand and the surgeon says I'll
go check so he goes and Shep's with the
administrators right and they they come
back and they say yeah you have to fill
out these forms but we'll give you the
hand so they fill out the forms they
give the hand to one of the other seals
actually receives a hand because Aaron
now or has had to move to a different
Hospital that's a little bit better to
deal with the amputations and they've
got his hand with the intent to take it
to a taxidermist so in the meantime
they're keeping it in the freezer of the
hotel and they're taking turns
spending time with Aaron so guy will be
there at the hospital with there and
while he's in the other hospital and
other guys at the hotel and they're
flipping back and forth which is a
little testament to like all the way it
is for team guys are just looking out
for each other they care you Vic you're
in the hospital once someone's gonna
stay with you 24 hours a day it's
awesome right so one of the guys that's
back at the hotel room decides that
either he's got to go somewhere and he
wants to put the hand in the other guy's
freezer or he's gonna play a joke on one
of the other guys and put the hand in
his bed and so he comes up with these
different ruse to try and get the hotel
staff to let him into the room and
they're not having any of it because he
looks kind of shady or a team guy yeah
yeah
so he's oh he's telling him oh hey you
know my friend left his phone in the
room can I get in there and they're like
well no or hey well no actually he
wasn't his phone it was his ID and I
need to go like all that stuff that kind
of shot in a balcony like a criminal
yes so then he leaves to go to the
hospital I guess but they're suspect
they're suspect
the poor maid goes in there and finds a
hand in a freezer I have a picture of it
it's horrible it's all grey and just
like ripped off right there
so Adams family style yes and so they of
course call the police the police show
up and they just detain everybody yeah
of course
and then Aaron's in the hospital and all
the nurses come up and they're like hey
all these police are calling here they
need to talk to you something about your
hand so he's got to get on the phone and
explain to the police why his hand is in
the thing I think they probably
validated something with the doctor too
and you know calm him down that this
wasn't some kind of murder and then they
kind of settled everything they threw
everybody out of the motel Aaron gave
his hand to the taxidermist he had a
nice what they call European Mount where
the taxidermist and Texas is awesome
so they they mounted like the skeleton
hand is in this really cool mount inside
glass all done up for him and Aaron just
had he had the best sense of humor about
the whole thing you know if you're gonna
get depressed I mean losing a limb is a
is a pretty good way to do it you know
and in a lot of ways he's like some of
the stuff you see out of guys like you
know Travis Mills
where it's just funny you're not guys
like that you're not gonna bum them out
just gonna keep them going but yeah so
then that's obviously one it's like one
of many stories how does that translate
to like when you're dealing with your
with your family like so for instance my
wife when I when I had to go to college
I had to go to the University of San
Diego and this is my first time in my
adult life that I wasn't like in a
platoon and so I was I didn't really
think about it but and all of a sudden I
didn't have anyone to like attack
verbally all day because when you're a
seal platoon it's just constant you know
attack
in combat verbal combat sometimes
physical combat and so when I would come
home from school of course there's my
wife and I'd want to have some verbal
sparring matches so I started hacking
away at her you know
and finally after three months she goes
she goes she was she's a bread you know
she she says uh hey I'm not a team guy
you know and when she said that to me it
instantly I instantly realized exactly
what she was talking about and I knew
she was a hundred percent right I can't
treat my wife as if she's a thief I've
and a seal know and especially like the
weapons cleaning table when we're all
stuck there cleaning weapons is when
guys would just that's when the you'd
look for weaknesses in any spot in any
guy and just start pick pick pick and
waiting for the reaction yeah you spend
so much time with people and so much
time just waiting you know it's a
hurry-up-and-wait thing so Oh what are
you eating to do on a four hour fan ride
you know we're gonna destroy someone get
into a fight spilled Cheetos everywhere
it's just like total chaos and mayhem
but yeah it's all about that but that
but I guess what I'm asking is I know
you know iris obviously had to get
what's the word indoctrinated into the
life of beat cuz you know I met my wife
when I was pretty young
yeah and you are not that young no and
so you you know you how'd that work out
like so the ideal wife the I don't say
ideal and I feel that on you poor iris
listen to this but squared away let's
say that you squared away spouse you was
that look like it so I gotta go back to
if you look at my career and and you
know this cuz you said this to her
wanted you on the podcast like she's the
best thing that ever happened to me oh
yeah because she's completely squared
away and it's because she is so solid
and independent and so there was never
ever any aspect of me having to worry
about the homefront and there's a
constant she's like
very dialed in and challenges me like a
lot of my I had a lot of like pretty
far-right political views and then when
we sit down and have discussions and
stuff she's really opened my aperture up
on that but you know you look at her
history where she she worked on ranches
where she was the only female Wrangler
with a whole bunch of cowboys so she she
got it she had that aspect of what it's
what it's like to be around and then
around guys and then when I'd be messing
with her like that you know she's just
same deal as Helen let me know it's per
you and check
basically yeah and the you know this
this job that we have where we're
constantly going forward in harm's way
and they're there I chose my words kind
of part poorly on the last podcast when
I was talking about her I said that she
put up with a lot of stuff that other
women wouldn't and that that gives the
indication that she tolerated a lot of
shenanigans
negative she was the strength that she
had to have to be home while I was on
combat deployments and then deal with me
when I came back that strength most most
woman just can't deal with that kind of
lifestyle
and don't have that kind of what were
the words that you used on the last
podcast she pulled up with a lot yeah I
said oh yeah and so that that was a
really poor choice of words because it
indicates like she was just a pushover
and she isn't absolutely not a pushover
yeah it's more yes more like she had the
strength to contend with the the hard
life that it is exactly being married to
some guy that's going on constant
appointment and isn't around a lot and
then when they're gone by the way they
might die they might come back horribly
wounded whatever and you sign up for
that as well and she's working long
hours and raising two little kids well
I'm going on six month deployments
and then she she also like in and I
pretty much I stayed in contact with her
pretty often so we we pretty much talked
at least three times a week three times
a week on deployment and um and that's
the model at work for us I've described
it and I forget who I described it to as
emotional independence but my wife had
has and had enough emotional
independence that she was gonna run the
show if I'm not there it's not freaking
out you know yeah and I think that's if
you're gonna look for a good spouse they
got to be you can't be they can't be
codependent right codepen is actually
actually like a bad thing right I mean
that's an actual bad thing right
codependency yeah yeah so II but if you
go to the other end of the spectrum or
not maybe I don't know maybe there's I
guess we go too far on that spectrum
then you get to where hey I don't even
know you're gone I wasn't aware of that
sorry I'm gonna do my own thing these
are you but you got to find a good
strong balance probably leaning towards
independent in my opinion you gotta be
leaning towards independent because if
you're not leaning towards independent I
mean when you don't get the you you know
it sucks being here by yourself for six
months it's not a true partnership if
they're not equal right if you're kind
of not equal footing and one person
really needs the other one then then the
partnership at ship aspect of it is it's
not there yeah that's uh that's
something to pay attention to because
the thing that's kind of weird
is when you're young guys get suckered
into the being habits it feels all
empowering to have someone that's all
dependent on you
You shant oh yeah and you're young and
you got the Carl and she's all dependent
on you and the world revolves around you
and then when you're not there she's
falling apart and you feel oh yeah I'm
the man and so it's easy I think that
I've seen that happen a lot where guys
get suckered into those situations and
that's not a good situation to get it
never works out because in there like
who's
and then she's in a situation of girl
she's gonna find someone else to take
care of her while you're not there take
a paragraph and then the case with iris
is like we're inside the same box as far
as just the things that we enjoy where
we want to be in the outdoors it's it's
all the same thing so you know it's like
I said in my retirement ceremony when I
look look I look at the trajectory of my
career and then when iris and I became
together
I went from platoon chief to Master
Chief first time up every time and just
hammered it because she was a good
partner and she drove me to be better
and is always driving me to be better it
helps to have somebody that's super
squared away like that you know what
that does it forces you like you're not
doing it for yourself because it's easy
sometimes easier to let yourself down
right you know it's easy to let yourself
down than to let down this person that's
that's looking at you thinking hey you
could do better than that come on are
you serious right now and and that's the
kind of stuff that you'll say to me you
know she's very straightforward nobody
go I'll just say check got it and then
we've gotten to the point where we can
give each other pretty honest feedback
without there being any resentment
involved I've been pretty
straightforward with iris on some things
we're working on some projects together
yep and it's pretty cool for me to be
able to just be real straightforward
with her you know yeah and she's like no
tell me who actually know how does she
says it she says no go ahead and tell me
yep Jack so you know speaking of
Afghanistan you're you you you you did
the last time you were on you know we we
breeze through Afghanistan pretty quick
we did but that was actually a really
pretty big deployment in terms of what
you guys did there you know and I know
there were some details that you wanted
to get into on some of those operations
and some of the things that you brought
home from those operations lessons
learned etc I mean you were talking on
one earlier talking about the MA deuce
and bringing the MA deuce that's it
that's it that's a good piece of gear to
bring out on an operation yeah and
usually you got it marked on mounted on
top of a truck but uh um when we did
that that operation as Frago 6 and siege
engine and we actually went into marcia
and the element that i was with was in a
blocking position that was looking down
a road that ran east-west and we were
the furthest east position so we were
blocking position on on that direction
and where we got dropped off was really
close to where we were gonna stay for
four days so we were you know we brought
a mortar and we brought the m2hb heavy
barrel 50 Cal machine gun with the big
tripod for it and everything how did you
break that up how many guys would carry
that that's a lot of weight to carry man
he'd sum up the ammunition and the
weapon and the tripod well the
ammunition got pair dropped into us but
the initial the initial insert we had an
eighth ATV on the helicopter and a lot
of that stuff was loaded on the ATV plus
we were inserted maybe 200 yards from
the position everything was kicked out
of the helo staged we went and cleared
the building and then hauled everything
over there and set it up and we done all
that you know the imagery set up for ok
here's what we're gonna be here's where
our firing lanes all that's all that
stuff was pretty much set up ahead of
time once you guys were doing that we
started the guys and trade that let that
we were putting through training started
doing it started carrying him in there
was some big team guy oh he just got
back from deployment I know exactly who
used all three the 50 Cal like he looked
like he was carrying a sixty he did and
it was so legit good to watch his
nickname was pig nip his nickname was
pig mess he's a beast
I know he's listening good on you that's
one of one of my favorite nicknames
you wanna have some feature about you
that gets noticed in the day because
everyone's gonna call you by some weird
name and the funny thing about him is he
is super he's a big guy and he's super
intelligent good good guy everywhere you
measure it so we set this thing up in a
window in you know inside so just the
barrel was sticking out and of the
compound that we were holding aiming
right down the east-west road because
our biggest fear is a vehicle-borne IEDs
on the road and along across that road
there was this there was like a hedgerow
and there was a little irrigation ditch
over there and so the Taliban kept
coming down that hedgerow and firing at
us from the trees and then just put that
50 on the tree line stitch it like at
shin level because that would be Chester
a little bit high level for somebody in
the ditch and just send a belt all the
way down and back and then push them
back further well at one point some guys
had come up from a different direction
and they were getting really really
close in this tree line bad guys bad
guys the Taliban guys and we could not
traverse the gun over far enough so we
tried to shove it out the window it
wouldn't go out the window
so me and yo D warned officer who was
with us and then one of my e5 suit right
now he's a troop esier over at one of
the SEAL Teams drug the thing out and
put it in the street and just started
laying it down so we got the 50 cals set
up in the street right out in front of
our compound and for a second there we
were taking heavy fire
pretty heavy fire a PKM fire but it was
all going a little bit high and we just
kept stitching stitching stitching and
then they were done they broke contact
they did not like that big gun in fact
the next day it kind of slowed down for
us because they didn't want to come you
know
they're like we'll find a different
direction because we were holding you
know basically four square blocks so
they started penetrating in from from
different directions then later on
two days later guys pushed out to
another building that was about a
hundred yards in front of the position
and they got into a little tick up there
so we started lighting up the area that
we thought they were taking fire from
and the 50 cow was so loud that they
thought that they were taking direct
fire from the 50 Cal when we were
shooting some of the rounds passing by
them on the rounds passing by them
they're so loud and knocking dust off
the wall that's all I was saying I can't
even imagine what it would be like to be
in a building yeah in you know that one
situation that Tony was in where there's
so much light in your building up with
several hundred rounds ya know the blue
on blue situation those guys put 150
rounds into 150 rounds of 50 Cal from
Lotter know 20 meters away and on the
corner it was a building on the corner
and they stopped in the corner and just
shot and those guys coming out of that
building after we got the thing under
control I mean I kicked open the door I
saw Tony there and and then but the and
Tony looked pretty much just like normal
Tony yeah everyone else in that building
look like they just saw death and they
actually just did see death I mean yeah
they're in a building they get a hundred
and fifty rounds of 50 Cal the guy that
was on the roof he was he was telling me
he was tell me there's like a year ago
like we were just talking about he goes
he goes yeah I got out my pistol i 100%
thought that we were gonna get overrun
and I was gonna die if I didn't just
take round through the concrete into my
head right yeah so did they know it was
blue and blue or they think that their
skin hammer glow it's just like one of
the one of the one of the many little
like components of this so that guy the
guy that was on the rooftop that I was
talking to 12 hours before he was in
another position and he got lit up with
a dishka 12.7 millimeter you know weapon
which is the Soviet equipment of the 50
Cal for those of you don't know
he got lit up with that and hit with
RPGs
so he said I remember it as soon as you
know as soon as this was all open we got
back to base he that's another thing he
told me but he told me this way back
then he said he said to himself I can't
believe the guy with the dishka found me
again it was so you so and we were only
you know a couple days to play and and
that same guy if there's some when he
got lit up here's in this he was in a he
was on Camp Corregidor in an overwatch
position looking for ID in places he's
sitting there on a sniper rifle and all
of a sudden he starts taking machine-gun
fire and it's it's a dishka and then he
gets hit with a couple RPGs
well I'm inside with the company
commander from from the from one of the
companies from the first and five or six
and we were planning an operation that
we're doing the next day so we started
hearing gunfire and all of a sudden we
hear RPGs boom boom and I said to him
via the machine gun fire starts and he
goes oh listen we're in contact and I go
hey my snipers are up there don't worry
about it
like just Jaco the badass right yeah and
all of a sudden boom boom so we hear the
RPG set so we go run an outside and I'm
still just I say hey don't worry my guys
got this in right as those words are
coming out of the bottom of the sniper
tower because we were right next to it
out of the bottom of the sniper tower
out pours that guy I'm sure will be on
the podcast one day he comes pouring out
of the tower his his weapon his sniper
gun had been blown like the stock up
blown off bro Lyda RPG and he he just
looks like oh my god I said okay well
maybe not
it was horrible but so that's the guy
when they're getting when they're
getting shot up with 50 Cal yeah he just
thought and the rest of the guys do
because everyone knew that this had
happened no he briefed it hey V hey just
imagine the the PLO going off to this
I'm saying hey guys these guys have disc
12.7 millimeter you know anti-aircraft
gun out there so be ready for some
significant heavy weapons and sure
enough that's the guy on the rooftop
thinking to himself I can't believe this
guy was a deal I found him again yeah
man the end and that was one
the big lessons learned when I got to
trade at where guys would put 50 rounds
of 50 Cal into a building with blanks
you know simulating combat and and then
we have a tray that guy in there that
would get up and shoot someone and
they'd be like that's [__] you know
that guy that that would never happen
and I'm like oh yes it would happen you
know you we had guys survive 25
millimeter chain gun from from Bradley's
and still stumble out of room but you
know not friendlies right not for me but
but uh we you know there was enemy that
made it out of buildings that had
whatever however many rounds a bunch of
25 millimeter chain gun rounds coming
out of the building
they're coming coming in your building
and they'd still live so you don't know
what's gonna happen with bullets you
know you just don't know how to tell and
that yeah
the frustration and the blame casting
that goes on some of that training we'll
get into that later but man gosh that
that 50 Cal is such a badass weapon and
then you know later on we had those
things mounted on our trucks and the
clearance of Mosel guys were stopping V
bids that are completely armored with
those things just hammering on him but
then it's on a crows remote system and
does a number that's just a beautiful
thing it's incredible that that gun was
made in the early 1900s yeah yeah yeah
for sure and on browning yeah that's an
incredible weapon use the exact same
weapon today that's amazing that's a
feat of Engineering someone was asking
me when I posted pictures of all the
brass all over the floor of that room on
on Instagram they're like oh did you
have any jams oh we know how to set our
headspace and timing got the gauge right
there on it boom that's a that's an
awesome weapon now another way you know
you were telling me another one about
getting extracted in like like a like a
like a Russian like hip 17 so the arm we
went into this operation in sorry pans
way which is a really really hot
area and we didn't like to drive
anywhere because Afghanistan's limited
you know it's limited roads and so their
IEDs threat was huge plus there were
culverts everywhere so they would just
pack all the a culvert full of
explosives and I could blow up like you
know to and wraps kill everybody that
and so we didn't have helicopter support
for this one operation but we were
working with the DEA fast teams and they
had their own helo support and they had
these mi Seventeen's which are these you
know Russian helicopters which are super
durable helicopters and um contracted
you know American pilots in him
obviously okay that's cool and so they
had this operation they're like hey you
guys want to go on it with us so we're
you know we're the main force on that
and it was during one of our turnover
ops that was actually the OP after the
when Dan lost his leg so he did it too
and get dropped off first thing in the
morning going clear to compounds and we
found a whole bunch of on that there
were fields and fields of marijuana
around here and then on that operation
one of the compounds just had a whole
bunch of cash was like huge burlap sacks
of up hash and I think I think they said
there was 200 pounds of it that in the
middle they destroyed it and so it was
the typical thing that happened
women and children left fighters came in
and then we were in you know a 360
firefight and we're in the firefight and
over the radio we're hearing from from
our aircraft overhead they're saying hey
there's a white van and it's dropping
fighters off around you so this white
this white minivan is driving off
picking up fighters and then driving a
big circle around us and dropping off
fighters
so this is like an hour later firefight
that's that thing I did okay so this
story so about an hour later there's
they're like hey the white coming over I
because I'm on dual comm so I can hear
on the fires net and and that's like the
other radio frequency outside of
inter-squad comms for those if you don't
understand that is is this one where the
aircraft are talking and when we were
real talking I'm on both of them and I
can hear the aircraft saying that white
van is back and so all the sudden I'm
looking straight north at 200 yards and
I see a white van pull into the open and
stop in you know in an alleyway so get
on the radio where's that white van and
is it directly north or position and the
aircraft comes back yeah it just dropped
off two guys and they're stopped they're
looking at you right now
crack crack two rounds and then a 60
gunner just mows the thing down and
they're just done the roof
well firefight just kept going now the
mi 17s they can't fly after dark they
didn't have some kind of certification
so they had to come in there and do a
hot extract on that LZ to get us off so
there's there's bullets flying all over
the place we get stacked to set our
breakout so everyone's kind of broken
down from their position we still have
security there they're setting up the LZ
and then my job as the senior enlisted
guy on my aircraft was I run out I'm the
first guy to the aircraft and I count
guys getting on and on the last guy on
that aircraft so that aircraft isn't
going until I have whatever number of
people getting on it getting on it every
place piling on there I get off like I'm
like I got a flag count and there's no
seats for me so I got a hop on the ramp
and hook an arm through one of the guys
legs my feet are dangling off the ramp
as we take off and then I'm shooting
just half us from the hip because it's a
cool robot
just for John Makua just for the call of
the apocalypse and alcohol at at you
know a place we were taking fire from as
we took off and then we got out of there
that was all it was a lot of fun I'm
gonna stop short of saying is awesome
because I'm not gonna use that word but
it was pretty great doesn't it Meriden
awesome right there that's a con spray
yes it was and no one got hurt no one
got wounded no no amazing but you said
all these bullets are flying around and
it's just incredible because just the
laws of chance yeah well those aircraft
too you know it's like those old-school
aircraft like when you read about the
Vietnam guys and I'm reading a book
right now those aircraft they were
flying these King they were dad
Vietnamese pilots in these King bee
aircrafts uh-huh and those things the
guy came back from one up they had 48
holes in it been shot 48 times and and
this American SF guys looking at the
aircraft and he's looking at the pilot
he's getting in like you were and he
gets in and he lays looking like this
Vietnamese pilot and the Vietnamese
pilot looks cool he's just like Roger
and I got it's a great quote the guy
said something along lines of when I'm
flying I'm just thinking about flying
I'm not thinking about bad guys I'm not
thinking about bullets I'm just flying
my aircraft if it's my day it's my day
period in the story but that coming in a
hot extract like that that's sketch and
those guys they they come in super fast
and super less beats speeds on their
side and it is sketchy it's on I was it
random rush NER a helicopter a hip or
what do you a my 17 I just the the the
NATO term is like a hip but yeah I was
in Africa working and and that's like we
needed to get somewhere and the only
thing they could get us was he
contracted contracted helicopters but
there was but it was contracted pilots
too and I was happy to land on that one
those are a pretty common sight over in
there to understand a lot of the other
other agencies using those and somebody
had told me and I don't know if this is
true or not that they were they were so
inexpensive it wasn't worth doing the
maintenance on so when they got to a
maintenance schedule they just destroy
it and buy another one that's crazy
yeah when that and and I don't know if
that's true you know that's something I
heard from some guy over at the chow
hall who yeah who was well informed
apparently but those pilots were so so
good and they you know they were all
probably XTF 160 guys that were now
hired on by these other guys to do the
job
over there I was incredible so speaking
of wounded or in that case not wounded
but out you were telling me a story
about and I cut you off so you didn't
tell it to me
you're telling me a story about a
Taliban guy getting shot in the leg yeah
so last time I was telling you the story
about last time I was telling you the
story about the the operation where we'd
set pop flares out because guys were
able to get so close to us and during
that firefight one of our firing
positions up on a roof they're like hey
there's there was someone that had
circled around kind of behind our
position when we weren't taking any fire
for him they were in the process of
trying to flank us like hey there's a
guy back here and we just shot him we
killed him so stuff calmed down and I
talked the TU commander I'm like hey I'm
gonna press out with these two guys cuz
it appeared as if it was like right
around the corner around this wall and
we're gonna go see if if the guys got a
radio on them or anything like that so
we pushed out of the compound and we
loop around a wall but it's not just one
wall at several walls and we get a
little bit farther away so we round the
corner where the guys supposed to be and
there's no dead guy at all but there's a
guy standing 30 yards away on a hill and
he shooting at me
so I have got I'm patrolling my scar
heavy but I'd folded the butt
stocke like a dummy and cuz I you know I
thought that was a cool way to patrol
and so now I'm like oh no I can't
shoulder my my scar so I just tried to
lock it out on like we do at the mp5k s
yes a lot punch it out you just punch it
squeezed Adam missed him and then it had
a stovepipe in a jiffy jam so I just
took a knee and started to reload and
then cleared the jam real quick start
shooting me again but he was gone and
then he turned up again when when we had
when we went to do our extract the
following day we had to clear a couple
buildings near where the helos were
gonna land and then we found that same
guy with his leg all bandaged up because
they didn't kill him they just shot him
in the leg and then we just wound up you
know leaving him there well so like so
was that the last time you patrolled
with your scar have you with the stock
folded the adverb then you know on
another op it was that I learned the
lesson of never taken off my body armor
an helmet because it was hot yeah yeah
what happened on that one oh my goodness
so we were it was an Operations wali cot
where we'd taken high ground above a
couple of compounds that we'd cleared
and the next day the Talib we'd gotten
to the point right where we we'd started
to get a little bit complacent and all
our engagements with the Taliban we'd
always had the upper hand against them
we'd completely we had airpower we had
better weapons we were trained better
and on this operation we had a piece of
high ground right behind the compounds
that we was everyone wearing it was
everyone using the eight cogs on their
on their scars generally or what were
they using guys variety of a cogs the
snipers actually took the the Scopes off
their sr 25s and put them on the
discoverer everyone
had basically everyone at scopes and so
lots of them and we had 300 Win Mag
sniper rifles that we brought along in
this I'm just thinking mentally from the
viewpoint of where the enemies at like
you're reaching out and touching them
accurately way further than they can get
you pretty much which a lot which again
will leans towards you thinking yourself
we're gonna kick these guys ass every
time yep and then you did kick their ass
a bunch of times and and so then these
guys start to take a high ground all
around our positions and we can see a
guy pushing out with a PKM onto this
flat ledge of rock he's 1100 yards away
and we're shooting at him with a 300 mag
but it's windy and and we're missing
we're missing clothes and he'd go back
and then come back out go back come back
out and they were getting set up all
around us and then they just brought it
they let us go with a salvo of
rocket-propelled grenade grenades and
then just steady PKM fire and we thought
there are thousand yards out they really
can't do that much oh it's you know 105
degrees out so we'll take a body armor
and helmets off and then that just laid
the hammer down
luckily for me I happen to be right on
top of my body armor helmet cuz I was in
in the prone position and then I just
was able to snake into my body armor and
get my helmet back on my head and you
know in this this is a position where
this was the first time we'd been
somewhere we couldn't fill sandbags so
we just stacked a bunch of rocks as best
we could to make a fighting position and
the bullets were just steadily hammering
the rocks and hammering the rocks and
hammering the rocks and I was thinking
man alive I'm gonna get shot and I
wonder if it's gonna hurt but it's
definitely gonna happen the odds are
odds are there and somehow it didn't and
then then beat up b-1 bomber came on
station and dropped a whole bunch of
ordnance and laid a hammer down but how
after that and I ran out of water we all
ran out of water up on this high ground
position I was like a hundred and twelve
14 degrees at 2:00 in the afternoon
we ran under water and there was no
getting any water until that night when
the Sun went down did you listen that
podcast with Ron Charan I'm sure I did
yeah the SF guy Medal of Honor recipient
but if you go watch the videos of that
yeah yeah that like the castle that
they're attacking that's crazy
just straight uphill I was just I
couldn't believe that I when I as I was
reading like I was reading a bunch of
articles about the situation yeah and
then they kept talking about video nice
and out you know check out YouTube and I
saw I couldn't believe it I couldn't
believe it and the way he described it
it was just incredible yeah he just laid
it out there's like oh yeah you know
yeah he's so understated uh-huh he's
like well you know it was a little bit
of a hill no there's a big building a
friggin awesome guy you know another
thing that we were talking about and you
made obviously this is getting leave in
Afghanistan it's getting back early in
your career when you were when you
failed the stalking section of Sniper
school and then you went back and you
and you you know you obviously made it
through you passed this but the the
stalking section and you kind of touched
on it when you were on last time but I
was wondering like a little bit more
granularity on what you changed that you
went from failing the stocks to alright
here's here's me knocking out whatever
attend yeah and and it comes down to
basically doing what I'd been taught and
and people were telling me is that you
start the stock you're told to find the
o P which is you know twelve hundred
yards away and the first thing you've
got to do is figure out where that
opiate observe NOP is an observation
point and that's where the guys that are
grading you on the stock who are other
sniper instructors that's where they're
at
and you you take that this model and I
was just thinking how it applies to
problem solving basically across the
board where okay I need to find a goal
in my future here somewhere in this case
it's the stalk and then before I start
executing on moving toward that that
goal going to find that Opie I need to
take some time and study the terrain and
see what my you know line of attack is
gonna be and how I'm gonna move all the
way up to where to where I'm gonna go
and then I need to put it into action
and while I'm putting in action I'm
constantly reassessing that goal and
adjusting my actions across the way and
that when I went from that model I went
from you know failing stalks to being
the first one done hardly spending any
time on my belly and doing that so then
you take that and you apply it to life
and you think about just goal setting
where do where do I want to be in five
years and identify it and then say okay
do a little research how do I get there
and then get on that damn path stay
disciplined and then just keep the eye
on the target and keep adjusting your
aim as you go and I can look back at
times in my life where really I wasn't
paying attention I'm really just
treading water you know living paycheck
to paycheck doing whatever and now you
know I take take that model and I apply
it to where do I want to be in five
years where do I want my kids to be what
kind of parent do I want to be and how
am I gonna get there and what's the path
I'm gonna lay out for it yeah that's
from a leadership perspective obviously
this applies because from a leadership
perspective if you're and I was just on
Peter Tia's podcast and we were talking
about a little bit about that strategic
framework tactical right yes I mean at
this point and
and you know what I said to him that
where it first started to occur to me
that was hey if my guys don't know what
it is that we're trying to accomplish
well they can't make it they can't they
can't move in sure I can tell move eight
yards forward and then they can't hear
me anymore now what they're gonna wait
for me to get wherever they are I can
say go take that building right there
well now they can't hear me anymore so
now when I go they're gonna sit there
and wait for me to come up and tell them
to do something else no they need to
know what we're trying to get
accomplished and then they need to have
this the standard operating procedures
down well enough so they and the
parameters that they're allowed to
maneuver within and that allows us to
actually accomplish the mission and
that's something I think I I mean I
don't even know when I learned that but
without that strategic objective and
that's a strong word okay I get it I get
strategic I get what it means and I'm
not talking about you know global
warfare but when you're in a town and
you have a mission objective that okay
we're gonna get to this building or
we're gonna move to this area or we're
gonna take this piece of terrain and
everybody knows that and even when those
things change because as you know you
get into a contact or you get into a
situation where you change what you're
doing you have to let everyone know that
hey we're breaking contact we're getting
out of here hey we're going strong with
this building or whatever once everybody
knows that then they can act on it then
they can carry it out same same thing
that boy you're talking about they're
now on a bigger picture of course that
still applies on a bigger picture if
your troops in the field don't know what
it is you're trying to achieve then they
make bad decisions if they don't know
that you're trying to protect the
populace if they don't know that that's
the broad strategy then they get out
there and treat the populace they'd act
like idiots if they know that's what
they're trying to do then they make
better than us and they make perfect
decisions because they don't but they'll
make better decisions because they
understand what that broad strategies
and it's certainly the same thing in
business and with business it goes back
and forth to biggest business sometimes
in business you're you know I run into
it with businesses where they're for
instance trying to go public so they
need to make money every quarter they
just show that profitability increase
and so the biggest thing that got on
their mind is trying to show a good
quarter and they'll sacrifice
some strategic things like sacrifice a
little bit of taking care of a customer
because they want to scrape a little
more money out of it out of the
situation that's a bad strategic play
but they do it short term at the time
because they know they got to make
morning the quarter so they can come
back and reinvest more so but
everybody's got to know that because if
everyone thinks hey hey the number-one
thing is we never let our customers out
okay guess what we lost money this
quarter now we now we can't go public
because we and again this is really
kindergarten level examples but that's
the kind of thing where what you're
talking about if people don't understand
what that longer-term goal is then they
can't really operate and function on
their own which is a problem no I mean
you're not thinking long-term you're
just thinking day to day basically yeah
like I kind of went off at the muster on
that one kid that asked me how often are
you thinking strategically and how often
are you thinking tactically and you know
I just kind of was going off about look
man every single thing I do is strategic
I'm not making any tactical moves I'm
not I'm not worried about the tactical
wins and losses now there's a reason for
that I'm in a good spot right now where
a little tactical loss doesn't mean that
much to me right now and it's really
easy for me to just focus on the
strategic stuff you know when I was
younger I had to focus more on some
tactical things you know that's the way
it is but even as a young person you got
to keep that stress you know you might
have to take some tactical you might
have to you might have to make some
adjustments and win some tore torn
battles just this because that's the way
it is but you should be thinking tactics
all the time I start you should be
thinking strategy all the time you
should be thinking long game all the
time all the time thinking about the
long game all the time think about how
is this decision affect where I'm gonna
be in the long term
cuz the short term decisions those are
the ones that beat you down yeah I've
gotta find that long game
nested inside that long term goal you
know strategy yeah yeah I actually kind
of appreciated that he brought that up
Oh totally it was a good question he was
a and he was a younger guy and you could
see he's thinking you know it probably
fell he probably thought to himself hey
it seems like Jocko keeps talking about
the long game and he thought to himself
how often is jockle thinking about that
and so he asked the question good on him
so I could explain I'm thinking about it
all the time I'm thinking about all the
time that's the way you got to do it and
it'd be tortillas well for bringing that
the whole framework of the bringing the
whole framework and everything up
yeah first aspect of that correct listen
to that this morning I'm like yeah this
lays that's the same thing that makes
you successful on a stock choosing that
goal and then working your way to it
doing your you know and you got to watch
out for the situation where you get
paralysis by analysis or and that's
caught up by the you've got a time limit
on a stock okay you've got three hours
to get this done
so you got to get it figured out and
you've got to get moving or I think a
lot of people will fall into that trap
where they do too much study too too
much study oh yeah and then there's life
in life in general sure any in stocks
guys we'll run out of time
I said something the other day most
things don't get finished because most
things don't get started I think you
won't even start building make that move
right of course
hey guess what big shocker there's a
dichotomy and that's the bottom line
there's a dichotomy if you rush into it
and you start moving without having a
long term plan
you're probably gonna make it a bad move
if you take too long you're gonna wait
too long and the whole it's gonna pass
you by yeah
so you have to constantly modulate and
figure out where you're at and no one's
gonna be able to give you the answer I
can't sit here and be like oh you know
what you want do anything you want to
make this know no one's gonna be sitting
there telling you that day by day you've
got to figure that out
and you got to figure out if it's really
really moving you in the right direction
you know way it's got to be when you
were talking about coming back to trade
at and you know you and I both had the
the luck to be at trade at in the
positions we were in I was the I was the
trade at oh I see you were the trade at
CMC it wasn't basically we were the
senior dudes we weren't together
unfortunately but what a good job and
what a good opportunity to see how
things unfold and what a good
opportunity
to take these standard operating
procedures and pressure test them
exactly so I was hit up the other day in
a brief where I was talking about when I
was there as a troop esier and we did
our first FTX and you had just trained
changed training to where we prior to
that and every time I'd been through
land warfare prior to coming through at
the troop senior enlisted advisor in
2008 our F T X's were all live-fire
great live-fire school but it's so
canned no because it has to be for
safety that it really doesn't put any
pressure on the leadership and there's
not really any pressure brought to bear
in any of your SOPs yeah to put this
simply to everyone when you're in a
gunfight there's two horrible things
that the enemy will do they will shoot
at you and they will maneuver and when
you're using live fire for training your
enemy is a bunch of paper targets at
best they're mounted on those little
carts that can move around but they're
very very limited not even remotely
close to what a human being is gonna do
so when you're going with live-fire your
enemy neither shoots back at you nor do
they maneuver so in the SEAL Teams we
would destroy our paper targets all the
time we would crush them all the time
relentlessly we were outmaneuver them
because they couldn't move we would out
shoot them because they didn't shoot so
it was pretty easy to dominate and you
sure there was that level of of stress
of the fact that is live fire and when
you're out like in the desert you are
and you and you do do and we still do
this where you have to shift fire and
you're walking and you're you know
you're you're making sure that you're
safe because you can't you know you can
you can shoot each other but that type
of stress compared to the stress of okay
now the enemy we're using we're using
laser tag guns or paintball and the
enemy isn't full-on maneuvering they're
full-on shooting back at us that's a
that's a big step up yeah and so we just
completely epically failed that first
operation
and we took a hard look at the four
biggest things we did wrong and
identified where our standard operating
procedures were flawed and then we sat
down with our leadership and we got
input and started to modify those SOPs
too so we could build up standard
operating procedures that were resilient
enough to withstand all the pressures
that you guys are putting on us in
training and someone asked me at a
keynote I was given the other day like
well didn't you guys have SOPs prior to
that and we absolutely did but they
weren't good good enough because they
couldn't withstand the pressure so they
had to be modified we had to modify the
way we were doing SOPs for getting head
counts we had to modify how we were
dealing with our down men like honestly
we weren't carrying litters around we
weren't but it's it's just an absolute
abject disaster if you get a wounded guy
sure I can drag him off the X but now if
I patch him up and I gotta throw him
over my shoulder again I'm gonna blow
out every bandage I just put on him
that's stupid
you know um our radio comms going with
when everything is confusing we had to
fix that so we had to dial those SOPs in
the standard operating procedures and
the beauty of tradit is that as stuff is
happening on the battlefield
we immediately modify that in the
training and we're putting that on top
of the guys and training so they can see
if their standard operating procedures
are good to go or if they're flawed and
they need to be modified so we can
constantly modify if people are honest
about them yeah and that's that's the
beauty of the basically the petri dish
or the lab that we had out there are
tradit because the other thing is we
could see when when people were being
honest about their mistakes or when guys
were were blame casting and not taking
ownership of what was going on and and
not being honest with their SOPs and
then you just develop these SOPs
like they don't just apply to the
battlefield we came up with standard
operating procedures for you know how we
did our admin stuff how we dealt with
with anything that you can think of we
would think of a good way to do it and
then test it and then run through it so
you know you might not like this this
analogy but I think that SOPs kind of
are a life hack because is one of those
things that you can layer is no work I
know except for the standard operating
procedure is pretty dang close to one
yeah you know what's as you were as you
were talking about that one thing that I
definitely noticed is the you could have
almost 90% of the time that you use the
word modify our SOP you could have used
the word simplify because most of the
time it was someone saying hey we got
this crazy we this is what we're gonna
do we're gonna do this and you're gonna
do that and there's all these crazy
things and they realize that doesn't
work so you make it simpler and simpler
now where that's counterintuitive is
like in extreme ownership where I talked
about doing SSE and when we first
started with SSE the plan was real
simple just smash everything and just
take whatever you'd find right that was
a horrible plan and it didn't work so we
had to we had to put something that was
a little bit more looked on the surface
to be a little bit more complex even
though when you broke down the
individual human beings of what they
were doing it was a very straightforward
and very simple so so yeah yeah no
there's no doubt that having that
opportunity to watch SOPs get tested and
either pass or fail and it was so
obvious either way because it was so
cool in the platoons and the taskings
would start to work together and they
start to cover move for each other and
they start to use decentralized command
they would they would crush the trade at
guys or they would absolutely would at
least get the best of them they'd at
least kill them all
whereas when they're not doing it there
would be comical Forte that guys would
kill 40 guys or whatever it was then you
just be thinking hmm
and you're right this is where you'd
have ego problems would show up because
guys would think and it was so hard from
from my perspective from your
perspective when you like listen the the
trade had cadre is going to do the same
there they did the same thing to last
nine troops or the last five troops they
did this exact same scenario and and the
other troops used simple standard
operating procedures that come to move
they use decentralized command and they
they won here's what you're doing this
is from my perspective and I know it's
hard but what you're doing is you're
trying to control everyone or what
you're doing is you've got these these
standard operating procedures that are
too complicated or you're not
prioritizing and executing you're just
you've got to follow these simple rules
and it would be hard to convey to some
guys if the guys wanted to put up their
ego barrier and and let it offend them
and think that would never happen or no
that's just the tree that guys knew what
we were gonna do yeah the tradit guys
know what you gonna do you know what
you're attacking a target area anyone
any any military mind in the world is
gonna get the high ground and then
they're gonna sweep through if they can
from high ground to low ground that's
what that's what everyone's gonna do
it's not like the trade at guys anybody
could figure that out any any military
mind is gonna look at a target and do it
one of three ways or one of four ways
and fifty percent of those four ways
actually is gonna overlap so you don't
have to be a freakin rocket science or
scientist or or or or Napoleon to be
able to figure out okay here's the
target where do I think the seals are
gonna come in from it's like okay
they're probably to come in from here
I'll set up two guys there there's also
a chance they're gonna come in from over
here co I'll put two guys over there
there you go
when you knew you knew our plan it's
like yeah bro the enemy is it's like you
talked about you had situations where
you went in and you're like oh we'll go
get on the high ground
oh the enemy put IDs there yeah guess
what it doesn't take a rocket science to
figure out oh if you're going to assault
us here you're probably wanted to get
this piece of this piece of terrain over
here so that would offend guys and
they'd get into the hey this is this is
wrong and instead of saying okay what
did I do wrong can you just use tell me
what I did wrong again cuz I need I'm
not sure I understand it oh well what
you did is this
you didn't prioritize next to you didn't
use the centralized command and they
would just say if you're not gonna
listen to that you know it's a problem I
had a guy at the mustard just to ask me
about like how do you handle it when
someone really picks you apart on a
debrief and I flag bro you know I a know
that I what I do is I look him right in
the eye and I say thank you thank you
for telling me that please thank you and
and I appreciate it and I'm gonna go
look at what you just told me and I'm
gonna try and figure out if I can fix it
because otherwise that like you you just
I could see in this guy's eyes like he's
asking me that question because his egos
getting offended I know everyone's ego
gets offended mine isn't
I get offended when somebody tells me
that when somebody gives me the nine big
debrief points on what I did wrong I'm
frickin mad I don't want to make
mistakes I have an ego just like
everyone else if not a freaking larger
ego than anyone else and when somebody
tells me I did nine things wrong I'm
pissed I'm pissed at myself and it's
really easy for me to look you get
pissed at you for telling me that I
screwed this up but instead I've gotten
old enough to realize even if I don't
like it was even harder if I don't like
it it's even harder when I don't like
you it's even harder right yeah that
makes it super hard but when you go you
know what guarantee you bite down and
you go okay thank you let me assess what
you just told me if you could make that
little step up in your life it's epic
and when guys would to your point when
guys wouldn't make that step in that
step up in coming through the trade at
training it would be a nightmare it was
a nightmare and the thing is man like I
love all these team guys I want him to
go kick ass I mean all I wanted was them
to like go do great things on the planet
and when you get that the guy coming
through that just would be offended Maya
and Ike I'd be so bummed out I'd you
know I just I'd be so bummed out I'd be
like product ID smart you do good I'm
just telling you like don't focus on a
head count when you're in the firefight
that's all I'm saying
yeah and then then you get to the point
where
you're just like oh man you're not gonna
get it now I'm just gonna make you
suffer yeah
but the because you get you'll get
critique points where guys will say hey
we need to get an op so we can go start
to finish
where you let us win basically hmm and
you know if you're playing football and
your college team goes against the high
school team that's not challenging for
anybody and you're not gonna really
learn anything out of it and that's a
learning that's why I gave you a
walkthrough and so after seeing that so
many times and running land warfare I
started going out at the front day one
and saying hey guys listen you're gonna
get a walkthrough that's your time to
work through your whole script on how
you're gonna run a target assault but
I'm shortchanging you if I'm not putting
pressure on you when we have these FTX
nights because we only have this place
for a limited period of time and this is
where you're gonna find where your weak
points are and get better and then
knowing about myself when I have those
two voices arguing in my head the one
that's my ego and it's making an excuse
for everything that you're that someone
is debriefing me is picking apart and
the other reasonable voice which I'm
trying to turn the volume up on that's
going
oh yeah that's a fair critique yeah well
I got a little lazy there she shouldn't
have taken my body armor off that that
kind of stuff or or the worst was like
the OIC that would come out after you
were oh I see in if he came out to
training and he would find some stuff
that was screwed up and he's like why am
I the one fixing it and I'm like you are
exactly right and guys are good angry
he's like it comes out here and he calls
us out he goes we we deserve it
let's not do this ever again we cannot
have our boss coming out here and
looking at how we're running training
and calling us out and a lot of it was
for I'll give you an example go out to
an eye ads range and a platoon is
decided to have their
Stiga Norwalk point because that's gonna
work good for an immediate action drill
but that's not what you're really gonna
do that's patrol to contact that's not
what we're training in an immediate
action drill when we're training for a
sucker punch
and he's like what in the Wide World of
Sports is going on here and we'd be like
yeah but guys wouldn't want to tell the
platoon would be one of these small
things we're and that I failed in this
in leadership a lot of times where it's
just like I'll just let that slide I'll
just let them pretty soon everything
sliding and you're not really giving
people any guidance but um yeah
people call me you got to be honest with
the critique and look at it and then
move forward and at the end of the day
you always kind of know when you're
wrong and it to take ownership of it you
feel better about it because now you
have power over it right and then it's
like oh if I think that the the tradit
staff is cheating now I'm powerless
against it and it's just kind of a
stressor that I'm you know
exactly they're just gonna win it
doesn't matter
blah blah and then it's it's also on on
a tray debt it's and it's difficult to
to debrief people and not come off as
condescending that's a real skill and
that's the some guys are really good at
that and that's something I try to work
on and I I'm not perfect at it but to
give people constructive criticism in a
manner that they'll accept it wasn't
what is hard about that and treat it is
you don't really have a good
relationship with 50% of guys that are
coming through so some guys that come
through like when you're coming through
them like hey bro like we I could looks
like beats pretty straight up with you
yeah some guys I don't really know you
and you're from like a different team
and I never worked with you before so I
have no sort of sort of relationship and
then it's a quarter you know to say hey
man that was a really bad job
you know now I I don't know I what I
decide what I ended up doing a trade
that was I would just be like hey this
is what happened you know and by the way
I really wanted you on my audio thing
like I would carry a little voice
recorder and then when people would be
panicking or freaking out I record them
and I'd say you were kind of freaking
out out there and they'd say the holes
are freaking out pick okay listen to
this does that sound like freaking out
two years at you're calm voice so the in
the other fun thing about the dead spear
was you could hit him with the near-miss
because if they got killed they would
get now drugged through the desert by
their ankle and guys didn't want to die
so they still weren't as honest about
fires they could be but they would still
like my favorite thing to do would be
put the god gun which is just a regular
thing I had as a lane grater on near
miss and if guys were screwing around
like they they would not you know they'd
all be standing up in a perimeter where
they shouldn't be standing and I would
just near miss them all guys would just
dive yeah I realized it was like
legitimate real rounds are covered out
or when they'd hear that near miss
things I didn't want to get drug through
the desert for freakin two kilometers to
the extract point have all their gear
beat up and bruised it had gone punished
all their floresta care use is getting
completely punished okay feel my face
but beautiful voice yes well how would
them younger guys coming out you know
everyone talks about the big Millennials
and I'm from what I've seen when I would
I'd talk to the teams and when I've gone
out to some training sites guys are
awesome I think across the board they
are yeah I mean I've looked at all all
the new guys and the the quality of the
new guys now compared to who I was yeah
I'm not sure I could have made it
through Katrina free if I was compared
against all the guys now they're smart
they're motivated and they're hard yeah
and they're only coming in because they
want to go to war because that's a given
yeah did I want to
more absolutely but it wasn't a known
thing I got to admit that I kind of
thought it was I thought like oh I'm
going to Nam yeah that was I thought I
was going to Nam in 1991 yeah the team
but yeah these guys know for a fact I
mean they they see they see you know
memorial services on TV they know what's
what they're getting into for sure
and the the complaints the complaints
about the Millennials that I hear are
that oh they want to know why they're
doing something well duh yeah you know
and you just covered that in that that
document that was written after or -
that says hey guess what you need to
tell guys why they're doing something or
they're not going to be the most
effective and it's generationally
generationally it's just more blame
casting where people are blinding about
the next generation goes back forever
that's just normal right I think it's
one of those normal yeah
whiny things that you gotta be the young
guys suck uh-huh no they don't you suck
when I was it one of the leadership
courses with some regular Navy
leadership and one of the Master Chief's
was telling a story that she had an e5
that she worked in in in supply and
she's like hey I need you to go do the
inventory today and she's checks back
comes back like an hour and a half later
and I had to go inventory this whole
warehouse and he's hanging out in the
coffee lounge an hour half later and
she's like hey what what the heck is
going on here she's like I did the
inventory and she's like no way that
takes all day let's spot jacket spot
just randomly pulls up a couple items
off that inventory list checks it she's
like how did you do this and he's like
well you know I got this app reader on
my phone
and I just went and scanned all the
barcodes used his phone and completed
the inventory like that with a little
bit of ingenuity and so basically she
just told him the end state and got out
of his way
was by accident but she got out of his
way and let him figure out how something
to do it and then then went with it
nothing wrong with that
nope what about for you as you've gotten
older what kind of mindset changes have
you gone through where like I just kind
of talked about one from my perspective
as I got older see see different things
and I always try and make that perfectly
clear to everyone that you know I kind
of you know I learned I learned and I'm
still learning and so you know would you
what what what like were some things
that if you could have learned or
changed your mentality on earlier like
what yeah I mean we're shutting down the
ego uh uh you know um a lot of my growth
honestly is being married iris and is a
hundred percent responsible for her and
here we go so to my ego down within has
honest conversations about well what are
you really thinking here and then you
know actually listening to what
someone's saying cuz the the trap I used
to fall into was when someone was
talking to me I wasn't really listening
to them
I was just formulating what I was gonna
say back to them formulating your
counterpunch exactly and I probably
score a high end trait disagreeableness
yeah so you know and it's just my nature
to want to be at that point of friction
but that also makes me just you know
want to go stick my finger in people's
eyes and offend them and stuff like that
and so stepping back and opening my mind
up to other points of view and then
being a little bit more cognizant of
other people and how they're reacting to
me so I can adjust how I interact with
them relationship wise I don't know if
you remember this question at the muster
a guide asked hey what what do
you how do you deal with someone who's
super negative and about you know the
the the the team or whatever and you
know I said here's a really good
leadership technique that you can use
it's very complicated
it's called listen how much you listen
to him but you actually listen to what
people are saying somebody's feels
really negative about my team guess what
I want to know why I want to actually
hear their explanation as to why they're
being super negative and by the way when
you allow someone to voice their opinion
and you listen to them carefully instead
of formulating a counterpunch which is
what our instinct is to do if instead
you go hmm okay what's wrong Jason what
mean what's what's the problem over here
I actually want to listen to you I want
to hear what you have to say and that is
such an advantage as a leader instead of
always feeling like hey anybody that
steps to me is getting crushed
no actually anyway that steps to me he's
gonna teach me something and I'm happy
to hear it
yeah boom and then just being aware of
you know but my biases the biases and
then I find this a lot of times with the
dang media presses the heck out of my
buttons and so I got to the point where
I just I don't watch the news anymore
yeah because the news is hard it's there
to get you angry so you'll pay attention
to it and gets them better ratings and a
lot of times when I'll see some really
extreme things that they're claiming
people said when I dig into when I
actually take the time to dig into it
it's like not quite what it was and now
that I've become a lot more
introspective and so I'm paying
attention to how things make me react
I'm paying attention to when my face
flushes out or I grip and I'm like okay
now it's time to detach and step back
I've noticed that just like it's Nas it
not a positive positive you know thing
in my life to have my blood pressure
spiked again and again and again
and again because I've got a 24-hour
news feed coming in yeah and so another
team guy pointed this out to me he's
like hey I was talking about the news
and I was all angry about something and
he's like you know what I quit watching
the news and he goes I'm a lot happier
since I stopped watching the news it
doesn't matter I'm like are you kidding
me of course it matters but he planted a
little seed and watered it and then I'm
like okay I'm gonna quit watching them
yes and it doesn't it doesn't matter and
I was to the point where I'll just check
the news like first thing in the morning
and make sure a volcano went off forever
now I don't even do that yeah if there's
a volcano going off I'll see the smoke
or someone will tell them yeah you're
gonna find out about it the 24-hour news
cycle is filled with a lot of things
that you don't need to know you don't
even know at all and that's that's the
kind of way I am I mean I still look at
it but it doesn't it I'm completely I I
can look at I can look at 19 headlines
in a row and none of them have any
remote impact on my mentality at all
until I see one that says oh there was a
terror bombing here and I go okay let's
see what's going on or hey there was a
US servicemen killed here and I'm like
okay but every other of the 17 headlines
that I read that were I'm trying to
think of a good one right now cuz
there's just you know everything is
going down either like okay fine yeah no
everything's not going down the world
isn't going to end but its clickbait
isn't the ìiî
you guys are the first ones I heard use
that word I'm like oh that's what that
is oh yeah yeah yeah exactly what it's
going on clickbait but it's just
clickbait on the TV to get you to dial
in and get him higher radius and then
you gotta listen that sam harris and i
forget the female's name that was on but
she did this whole research about it
talking about how the russian lost the
russian bots and all that stuff and yeah
you can create headlines that are gonna
make people click and then you can make
fictional random you can just make up
stories I know and peope they'll catch
you know someone else will report that
story as being true it's a crazy world
hold the onion is that joke newspaper
they've got AP is picked there
up like two or three times before
totally nuts
so you got to learn you should
definitely adil me the mum learn to
detach when you read the news yeah and
then something that I found real helpful
is is putting a filter on my thoughts so
the in and this is something that that
iris is kind of talked about she's like
the first filter is a my whining and
then the second filter is a my resentful
and then the third filter is a my
jealous and if I can just catch that
stuff once I identify it it doesn't
bother me anymore
yeah but prior to identifying it if I'm
just like oh someone's whole just got a
promotion
that's [__] he you know and then
then I realized oh wait a minute I
should be happy for him for getting that
promotion and Jordan Peterson says
something about be careful who you share
good news with and and and I just don't
that's not a that's not something like I
I'm proud of when I see it come up in
myself and that's one of the things that
that as I age I'm trying to fix the
other thing that that as I've gotten
older is I used to be very group
identified with and now I find myself
becoming more of an individual if that
makes sense no that makes that makes us
this this is that's where I'm trying to
go and this is this is the path that
that I'm on and it's a it's a struggle
when it all comes down and I kind of
wish there was two words for ego right
because the Eagle if I didn't have an
ego driving me to be better yeah I I
would just be sitting at home meat and
chocolate chip cookies all right on the
Commish there's not two words to
describe you go but there is the
dichotomy of it though there is so then
you're good to go yeah you know one of
my team guy buddies a long time ago we
used this phrase which I which I always
remembered because I thought it was
really good basically someone was
whining about something and you know
raised their hand and said woo
we doing this and then afterwards my
buddy goes hey that's cool put yourself
on report for being a [__] and so like
I've been hypersensitive to that for a
real long time I do not ever you know I
don't care what I'm going through I will
not complain about anything like I am
hypersensitive about that at least I try
to be I mean yeah you know cold and
baccala and mocking us anything you know
hurt I hurt my knee and I my knee was
also on a ball jacked up and I didn't
tell anyone I told my knee
nope no factor and finally life was like
hey you know it what's up with your knee
I sent my picture things like that knee
is just twice as big as the other one
he's like oh my god are you gonna need
surgery I'm like no no factor but and I
only sent it to him like six or seven
days that the swelling had gone down but
out of the gate I wasn't gonna say
anything cuz I don't I don't want to sit
there and complain like bro I hurt my
knee doing jujitsu oh no you know what I
mean like come on bro I'm not gonna
complain about that but yeah those other
things about being resentful and being
jealous whenever I feel that tinge of
when I feel that tinge of jealousy when
I feel that tinge of what I feel like I
feel like mad at someone for doing
something I automatically know it's me I
automatically and I've known that for
years
there was a STONER as a matter of fact
was going to he wanted to go to
Princeton mm-hm and he he said to me he
key and he I wasn't no we weren't we
weren't together a team three anymore
and so he was talking to some people and
finally he comes to me he says hey man I
want to go to Princeton I want to put
together this package and go to
Princeton he said but uh some of the
other people I'm talking to are telling
me it'd be bad for my career not like
bro those guys are just jealous that's
not happening I go you go and you get
your freakin degree from Princeton are
you kidding me how is that gonna be bad
for and he did he ended up doing it any
other guy he got in he got accepted and
but that was one of those things where
it was so obvious to me like whoever
told you that he's just telling you that
because they don't want you to
have-have another Punk card to pull on
you cuz like hey your stoner your you
know you've got a bunch of combat
experience you've got a bunch of combat
awards you're you're this big strapping
dude and by the way you're gonna go to
Princeton like no one wanted that final
Punk card to be issued disc odor it's
hard when you see someone else that's
successful and you know that like I
should be getting up off my ass and
getting into Princeton myself or going
and you know though you can't control
whether or not you're deployed to combat
a lot of other stuff is and I think
that's where it gets painful for guys
it's like okay well I'm not gonna make
the effort so I don't want anybody else
to make the effort either I'm a crab in
this bucket and I'm gonna drag that crab
that's trying to climb out back in the
bucket and this is actually in a way the
warrior Kid 3 this is why I had to
address this which in way the warrior
Kid 3 you know have you read it yet not
yet it's one way the warrior kid there's
a new character that comes his name is
Danny Reinhardt and he's like good at
everything you know better at mark then
ever and everything he's like a little
bit smarter does better on the tests in
school and he's a little bit faster and
he can do more pull-ups and then they
like to take the cake because he's a new
kid moves in and then mark still thinks
he's got the ultimate Punk card to pull
which is I do Jiu Jitsu and I can choke
you some of the stuff matters it turns
out Danny Ryan hearts been trading for
two four years and and that's exactly
what happens is Marc instead of saying
wow I can learn from you wow you can
help me wow that's awesome I know you
worked hard for that instead he just
tries to undermine and he just is
jealous and so that's something that you
deal with when you're starting to be
even as a little kid you know
even a little kid you can be jealous so
checking to check yourself if you're
being resentful if you're jealous of
someone those are like the first things
I check when I start getting mad at
someone those are the first things I
check when I start getting mad at
someone I go and I being jealous right
now yes I am hey that's a filter yeah
that is not it's not good and and what's
worked out really well for me is when
you identify these these people that are
good at everything keep them around you
Oh first of all for sure for sure
that's the other the other clincher in
in the way the word good three is is
Danny Reinhart he's not only like better
he's also like a really nice kid yeah
and so that makes Marc even matter
because everyone wants to be friends
with him you know just because he's nice
so yeah you gotta watch out for that
check yourself don't get that I wanted
to talk about some leadership mistakes
that you've made and I was thinking
myself while I could talk I could call
out Jason for leadership mistakes that
he's made that's kind of jacked up if I
don't talk about Indian leadership
mistakes that I've made now of course
I've listed a bunch of leadership
mistakes that I've made in that kind of
me of leadership and in extreme
ownership so there's that but I want I
got a couple that I thought of and I was
trying to think of some broad ones one
of them is when I was in Ramadi I hate
to start off like that when I was in
Ramadi I did not do a as good a job as I
should have and I'll go a little bit
further to keeping the rest of our
community informed as to what was
happening and why it was happening and
to be honest with you the reason I say
I'll go further than I just didn't keep
me informed I wasn't even thinking about
it I wasn't even thinking about it when
I got home and one of our good friends
said to me and he was all fired up and
he's like we were reading your he's like
we read your aar as a quarters everyday
like so he every day I trade at at the
time while we were in Ramadi they were
reading the a ours that the after-action
report for the a they killed nine guys
they killed seven guys that in that's
noise like hey that's awesome that's
cool I didn't really even think of that
but what I also didn't think of was guys
that were saying hey wait a second one
of these guys doing over there hey wait
a second wait why are you conducting
operations during the daytime hey wait a
second why are you staying out after you
get contacted why are you staying in
position hey wait a second why are you
working alongside the conventional
forces why aren't you doing stuff with
just special operations and I did a bad
job of explaining these things to
community as a whole and even when he
got back I had the opportunity to do it
I spread the word to some people and was
able to explain to him but by then some
people had already thought oh well these
guys were just over there dude doing
these rogue operations by themselves and
they should have been doing it so that's
that's one that's one big one that I
wish I would have done a better job and
I just I just wasn't even paying
attention and you know what it's like
man I mean this is my this is my excuse
is my it's my fault because I was over
there and I'm thinking like hey we got
an operation tomorrow I got two guys I
got I got two elements going on the
field I'm not worried about what their
thing yeah I just didn't even think of
it and I should have so I don't know if
that's an excuse it's the reason why I
didn't think of a way I should have and
I was wrong for not doing that how much
bandwidth could you've expended on it
though in the moment you know what if I
would have been a little bit smarter and
a little bit better I could have taken
15 minutes to send out an email and say
hey everyone want to let you know what
this Oppel is really like there in the
OP sums right the other sum is an
official document if I could have
supplemented that with hey guys
Jaco here I know this one sounds a
little bit crazy here's what's going on
the Iraqi soldiers that we're working
with they don't have night vision they
have one flashlight per fireteam to go
out at night with these guys is
completely it doesn't work and so we got
to go out in the daytime with them
sometimes and so that's what we're doing
here's why we're doing it you know I
could have done it I could have expended
a little bit and I just didn't have the
awareness that I should have had to
explain these things also to explain
them in plain English because it's one
thing to read the OP some that's a
official document that's written a
certain way it's another thing to say
hey guys
Jaco here here's what's going on and
because I mean let's face it at that
time I'd been in for a long time and I
had friends everywhere I mean and when
my friends would reach out to me this is
probably should have been my best
indicator some of my friends that
reached out to me and said like hey dude
what's going on like I heard you just
got a guy I heard one of you guys got
shot what's going on how is that
happening
and I had one specific friend of mine
who wrote me like a long email and and I
wrote him back right and said hey man
this is what's going on but that should
have been an indicator if one of my
friends was reaching out to me and
saying hey what's going on I should have
been more cognizant the fact that people
beyond and people that didn't know me at
all
you know would be thinking what you know
well this guy's this guy's a hyper
aggressive and they're just out there
taking too many risks it's like no and
and what was cool was there was some
guys that were in Ramadi other seals
that were in the body are working in
there in and around Ramadi at the time
who I knew and they were like all you
guys are crushing it you guys are doing
great this is awesome
you know but I didn't do a good job so
that's that's one thing I don't know
what it looked like from your
perspective where were you when I was
over there in Paycom poolside at
Thailand explaining to my guys why we
had to put the missions first yeah yeah
check check
yeah but at the time I was excited for
you guys because it was like the that
was like the first sustained heavy
combat yeah of that war yeah yeah
everything had been we were talking
about the big news to stand around and
talk about when you were at the bar was
was maybe a tick or a firefight that
lasted five minutes yeah and you guys
were troops in contact 100% of the time
every time you walked outside the gate
yeah it wasn't quite that but it was a
lot yeah and then that's for sure and
and that's what that's what I think I
think I should have explained that
better than I did
throughout the community and you know I
still talk guys I still have the
opportunity where you know some guys
that I'll I'll still explain this to
some guy that I haven't seen as you know
it is you'll run into that scene in 15
years you know they'll be like dude what
what you doing over there office okay
let me explain it to you I've had people
sit through kind of the Ramadi brief
mm-hmm and be like okay I get it I get
that makes sense
or hey Roger but yeah should have done a
better job of that from a leadership
perspective I was trying to think of a
tactical example of and this is really
easy story one time I personally chased
down some dude over
like multiple rooftops as a in Baghdad
you know like just gotten up one man
pursuit well I had another guy who like
trailing me but basically we're hitting
a target there's a squirter I'm outside
the ability
and also you know the the the overhead
asset reports that there's a squirter
and he jumped to another rooftop and I
had a radio man the radio man was like
near me and we both know the radio man
and he's like hey he's that guy he went
to the next roof and I was like got him
and so I climb up a palm tree
I climb up a palm tree like in between a
palm tree and like the garage and I get
to the roof and I get the notice he's
like you jump to the next one and so the
radio the JJ TAC is in the street with
me following down and telling me what's
going on and basically I left my I
shouldn't have done that you know I
should have sent a couple guys and
eventually I got someone else with me
and then we we got the guy but you know
I just was trying to think of hey where
did I make some mistakes where that were
more on a tactical level and that's one
right there is you know I I'm in charge
of the assault and if I'm out there
chasing the guy from rooftop to rooftop
I'm not doing my job but they did have
it on video and it was pretty awesome
and I tried to get a hold of it but of
course it's classified so I couldn't
have it but yeah it was pretty cool to
watch you know yeah and like parkour and
get funky yeah it's climbing a palm tree
and then jump from roof to roof to roof
and then eventually they're like hey
snap one right there and yeah so that
was one and then the last thing again I
was trying to think of like a variety of
different mistakes and here's something
from a leadership perspective that I
really when I look back I wish I would
have done a better job and that's
helping guys with their finances young
guys I mean how many young guys reenlist
they get a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar re-enlistment bonus and they show
up at work two days later they've got a
new Ford f-350 Super Duty
harley-davidson version and they have
you know they're they have up they have
a 60
$2,000 truck that is now worth they just
had it for a day and they've now worth
forty eight thousand already lost money
and guys that would let instead of bomb
you know just all those things where and
and I wasn't like super at it but I was
ahead and I should have been telling
guys like hey man let me talk to you let
hey guys let's do a little lives to talk
for a half an hour about where you're at
right now let's come up with a strategic
objective of where you're gonna be in
five years you know - you still want to
be Retton apartment in IB because that's
probably not great or do you want to be
buying a place get with what anybody's
so I never talked about that kind of
stuff and again what it boils down to is
my own my own being obsessed like I
didn't care about that stuff you know
what I mean I guess I cared about it
enough to do it and I got lucky I had a
I had an officer one time that said I
bought a house every three years and
kept it he just said that to me
and I was like that seems like a really
good idea and that's what I tried to do
uh-huh but I didn't pass that word on
and I could probably helped out more
guys so kind of a bummer on that one I
yeah because that aspect I completely
dropped the ball on that early in my
career as well later later on I got a
little bit better at it but you know cuz
I did 30 but I could tell a guy how to
be a good shooter yeah but then I didn't
look at the whole rest of the dang pie
chart and realized that if I fixed all
that other stuff they'd be an even
better shooter exponentially better
right and yeah that that that was
something that that actually helping
guys and there were stuff that this is
this is something I really failed at is
like I could see guys messing up but I
didn't want to have that uncomfortable
conversation with them to like bro he
you got a you got to kind of fix this
like hey you know you've used the
analogy before if I have a booger
hanging out I want somebody to tell me
yeah and so I see get mad at them
who's talking about I wanted that Booker
there no I I definitely wouldn't I I had
some of those conversations for sure and
I'm sure you did too like hey this girl
she's not the one I'm gonna tell you
that right now this isn't gonna work out
well for you the problem is getting
somebody to listen to that conversation
is real hard when it comes to the ladies
yeah and that aspect of just most times
it blows up in your face and then
sometimes you're just like hey I realize
that maybe I'm gonna lose my friendship
with you true but uh I gotta tell you
this and later on in my career when I
started to start like struggling with
anger issues that were probably a result
of my combat deployments and started to
go sit down with a psychic and I would
see you know you were super angry even
before wise I was like probably pretty
predisposed to it all and it just met it
just turned it up to 11 right and uh and
then I would see myself and other guys
and I would tell him hey man here's the
deal here's the psychs number I wanted
just to give him a call and you don't
have to see him after that but do me
this favor and some guys would help and
other guys the guy I made the effort and
they'll come to that conclusion at some
point but it's like son you know we got
to look out look out for each other and
do the best we can and that was
something that I you know missed out on
I think I probably would have made an
awesome platoon chief about the time I
was a ops Master Chief
two echelons above it really realized
what that job was because that as a
platoon chief one of the things that I
missed out on was that the guys are
always looking at me to set the example
and so it was one thing during working
hours I could set an example but if I'm
a buffoon out drinking too hard and
they're like you're an idiot or they
follow your example they and they
they'll follow my example and think that
this is acceptable behavior if if I'm
badmouth my leadership which is I'm
embarrassed to say it but it's the stuff
that if I didn't didn't really have my
aperture open on the big picture and
would complain about the command and
then I complained in front of the guys
just screwing them over and I did
because they're like well he's whining
yeah now I'm gonna go ahead and whine I
had issues where like personally I
didn't like the person that I was
working directly for and that that
tainted my interaction with that person
I didn't have any relationship with them
and then my whole platoon would suffer
because I had a bad relationship with
the next guy up just because I didn't
like him which is complete weak sauce oh
yeah I was having a conversation with
Dave Burke good yeah and it was we had
he just quoted me yesterday
yesterday I was hanging out with him and
well the quote was like whatever six
months ago we were having a conversation
and I said something like hey Dave
whether I love you or hate you you won't
know either way and and he was like well
it kind of freaks me out because you're
super nice to me and now I think just
hate me and don't care and you know we
laughed about it but that's exactly
right and that is the truth like the
guys that I hated never knew it I mean
to this day they don't know it and so I
mean you and I were having a
conversation about a couple of people
that I obviously don't like at all they
don't know that so so you've got to be
professional at all at all times and
it's a very small number of people most
people are pretty cool to me you know
and most people support what I'm trying
to get done so I'm pretty lucky in that
way but yeah if you if you let that out
that's bad
is there ever really a reason not to be
polite yeah very seldom yeah okay you
could politely punch
in the face usual people begin here's my
like oh well you know that's what you're
talking about your uncle you're you're a
kiss-ass
it's a actually let me tell you what I
actually want to do what I actually want
to do is I want to win what I actually
wanna do is I want to have my platoon
able to get the support that they need
what I actually want to do is I want to
be able to have my platoon get the
support that they need so that we can
actually do a better job doing our
mission that's what I'm doing what I
care about is my guys and my mission
that's what I actually care about and if
I've got to be polite to someone to make
that happen if I've got to overlook the
fact that someone might not be the
personality type that I particularly
like I don't care I don't care guess
what I'm gonna deal with it I'm gonna
accept it I'm gonna resorbed whatever
kind of crap that they want to throw and
I'm gonna deal with it it's fine now do
you get into situations where you
actually have a bad boss that you have
to show let's face it if I'm treating
you like a piece of [__] and and you or
I'm making really bad decisions and all
you do to support me and you're a
yes-man well your guys are gonna lose
respect for you so you there's times
where you have to say hey listen guys
here's what's going on I don't agree
with everything that the boss says but
you know what
he's the boss right now and what we're
gonna do is try the easiest way the way
for me to get him to make better
decisions is if he trusts me so right
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
kick ass and so suck it up quit
complaining we're gonna do a great job
and I'm gonna get a better relationship
over him when he will start listening to
me and we'll move forward and by the way
unless we're gonna have a mutiny which
we're not gonna have this is the best
option the other option is me to have an
antagonistic relationship with the boss
in which case all he's gonna do is screw
us over so how do you guys want to play
this
you don't mean so sometimes you got to
be transparent about that stuff and
that's fine too I mean I've I've been in
situations where I've had to do that
where it's like okay hey guys here's
what's going on I know this seems a
little bit crazy I know that the boss
may seem like he's making a rash
decision on this here's what we're gonna
do let's explain his perspective here's
what the boss is saying he doesn't want
this to happen again he's tightening the
noose is tightening the bleach way more
than I want him to but guess what let's
show him that he can let loose on the
leash again let's get in line you'll see
you gotta have those conversations
sometimes
but broadly I'm gonna get along with
everybody
why not I want to do my mission I want
to take care of my guys the best way to
do that is if I have good relationships
up and down the chain of command boom Oh
question what so and you know I don't
like you in your Vinay secret the secret
is out uh-huh yeah kind of got that you
do it in your view what um what's the
difference between that how you say like
you get a lot like even if you don't if
you really don't like someone thing
whatever nothing in your view what's the
difference between that and being like
uh what do you go like a two-face or a
you know like let's say always a
two-faced person or whatever well one
big thing is I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
not getting along with some said I can
so that I can better my own life I'm not
doing it so I can take care of me yeah
because I don't really care about me I'm
doing it so I can do my job well so I
can take care of my platoon so I can
take care of my team so I can accomplish
my mission that's number one if I'm
doing it so I can get the promotion I'm
actually the guy that I don't like the
guy that's like oh I'm doing this so I
can get promoted no I'm not doing that
and and that's another thing the troops
see through that every single time
everybody they they have a name for it
in the teams that guy is a ticket
puncher they're trying to get their
ticket punched oh he's just trying to
get his take a punch he's trying to grab
on the back guys grab a hold of that
person's coattails and ride him up you
know ride him up to the neck wreck it's
like no big everyone sees through that
if you're doing the right things for the
right reasons people like hey you know
what Jocko you're I mean and we times
people in let's do to your patient guy
late babban told me that hey you're so
patient I don't I don't see how you do I
don't see how you do it no this is when
he was younger like bro how do you deal
with that I care about our task unit I
will make this happen
I can I can absorb some impacts no
factor bring it I remember when I was
working the club there's a guy who I
thought was two-faced and when I listen
to you like how you're like oh yeah cuz
he said that before that you like if you
didn't like someone they probably
wouldn't know I was like oh yeah that
makes sense
you know cuz it like it helps the
relationship helps morale like helps all
these things right and then so think oh
yeah a two-faced guy there was a
distinct difference and one of the main
things on top of what you said because
what you said was like
I think a woman were thorough ultimately
view- a little bit more well should I
say straightforward to ground level I
guess can I guess what you're gonna say
sure but well because the other option
the other answer I was gonna give is I'm
not acting differently in one situation
I don't know hey boss yes I got it and
then go back to paternity go he's an
idiot no no I don't do that I go hey
boss you know what even if it was a
situation where I was saying like I
might go back and tell the guys like hey
guys this is what's going on I would
tell the boss I wouldn't say boss that
sounds like the greatest plan ever
ya know I'd say hey boss I'm not I don't
think I'm a hundred cent on board with
this I see some other ways we could get
this done if this is what you're telling
me you want me to do I'm gonna make it
happen but I think we could you know I'm
I'm gonna I'm sorry I don't act
differently yeah
I'm not I'm not a different person in
front of you know I was doing an event
the other day and I was like talking to
a company and I was backstage talking to
CEO and we were just used you know and
all of a sudden you know there's like
he's like hey it's only another half an
hour before you go on do you need some
time mm-hmm and I was like no I don't
need any time because the person that's
gonna walk out on that stage is me and
I'm not acting any different way it's
just me I'm gonna you know I don't need
to get into character I'm in character
I'm walking around on me this is me and
he was like oh that's awesome so same
thing I don't when I'm dealing with the
boss that I don't like or whatever I
don't show that to anybody
yeah act differently yeah you're you're
also you're doing a good idea good
you're managing what Hills are worth
dying on or sure when you go to your
boss so that you've built up that equity
with them no doubt about that when you
need it you can cash it in and that's
why you have to establish those
relationships with you and that's what I
really failed as as a young leader
before my aperture started to get opened
up before I got introspective and I
started thinking about all this stuff
from a big picture and then my little
ego was in the way yeah and um you know
if you're not if you're not the guy that
is bitching every time when you do bring
something up in a respectful manner
I'm gonna at least consider what you
have to say and nine times out of ten
they're actually gonna go with no
they're gonna go with it
yeah that's that's the that's the
extreme ownership story you know that's
the and it was me sitting around with
your tasking to commander the other task
commanders from all the different teams
and everyone's you know you could say
they got this problem that problem the
other problem you know in the the
Commodore at the time who was a friend
of mine says you hate jockle what do you
need and I was like hey sir we don't
need anything we're good to go
and if you like it you know for whatever
reason I was like the last guy to go so
it had even more impact because
everyone's complaining about this day or
the other fan salute he goes he goes
Jocko which is this and that they gave
anymore back because he's just like you
know he knows me he goes chuckle what do
you need I'm like nothing sir we're good
to go
and you can say you know four months
later when I go in there and I say hey
sir we need X he goes cool go to supply
I'm calling him right now
boom taken care of that's that's how it
should be another thing that I was
thinking about when you were talking
somebody asked me at some point you know
at which what point did you start sort
of like looking at yourself kind of what
you're talking about what point did did
I start to look at myself from an
external position and say from a
detached perspective insane wait are you
being jealous are you being resentful
are you complaining I can tell you right
now that when I stepped into a
leadership position what I knew was that
as you said every guy in my platoon is
looking at me and I looked at myself the
same way
I said because as a young enlisted
because my first leadership inside a
platoon was as an assistant platoon
commander I was an ensign mm-hmm and so
sure I was a little bit you know when I
was an e5 I was just I was a three
platoon v5 and are you in a leadership
position you know a little bit sure but
not really a little bit when I was a
platoon ensign I was thinking the whole
time these guys are looking at me just
like I used to look at my officer so if
I complain that it's cold
I complain that it's because when my
officers used to do that dude this sucks
oh really I'd be like I would I would
just I would I just I would get furious
and that's why that's the when I really
started looking at myself and I'll quite
frankly when I started putting in an
officer package as a young enlisted guy
and I was like wait a second these guys
I want these guys to think that I
actually should be in charge I need to
tighten it up they're looking at me
right now thinking why does Jocko think
he should be an officer here's why
here's I need to act like I actually
deserve this so that was a real
precursor to me looking at myself from
the outside saying man I know what it's
like to be an e5 in a platoon looking at
the officer going oh you forgot that
piece of gear did you and you're in
charge of me you're making more money
than me you're making the decisions
tonight on this operation you didn't
bring your ham set really that's where
we're I know what that felt like and so
I held myself to a high standard because
I didn't didn't want somebody to be
looking at me thinking Jacques was
complaining he's weak he's making a he
forgot a piece of gear he didn't show up
on time he didn't show up on time you
know many times I was late when I was in
the US Navy for 20 years
zero zero times late zero never why
paranoia high level of paranoia don't
want to have guys when my officers were
late and I'd look at him and think oh
you can't even show up on time
you're in charge of me you know that's a
young arrogant kid for sure absolutely
that's me but I I ate that and I held on
to it and that's one of the first things
that made me and at some point it turned
from this kind of hostility into like
you need to be a better person you know
if you're gonna be in charge it went
from like this attitude that I'm kind of
portraying right now of like oh you suck
into like hey you need to do a better
job you need to hold yourself to a high
standard you need to be a better person
if you can be in charge of these guys
you need to hold the line and you need
elevate that line so that had that
definitely had a big impact on me and
bro
if anybody knows this you do you knew me
when I was an e for twenty years old
maniac right you know and then you you
know you ran into me what however many
years later no seems a little bit
different you know not totally different
but because even when I was a young kid
I was fired up oh yeah but you know I
had to elevate had to elevate some yeah
that introspection is something that I
didn't figure out till way later but I'm
sure glad I'm dead because I think it
paid off
it's that's one of the things and it's
one of those things that you know did
your dad ever give you any advice yeah
so did mine how much I listen to this is
about the same amount as I listen to my
dad it's one of those things where
you're you you just there's some things
that you have that that you it's like
you can't be taught
yeah you you kids like someone can't
tell you this for some reason there's
some things that people can't tell you
unless you can just completely open your
mind and get humble and put your ego in
check which is really hard to do when
you're 22 23 24 like there's things that
I look at and I go oh you know what I've
heard that before I learned that lesson
I got told that lesson but I didn't
learn it but it's you can pick it up
pretty dang quick by by example and so
you know how often do you get people
asking you well how do I get that guy
over there to take extreme ownership
yeah like you do it yeah that's you take
extreme ownership and it will be
contagious yeah yeah um and in in that
manner when people see those modeled
behaviors then it just goes out and it
goes back to that thing that life talks
about there's no bad teams there's bad
lead
and I've seen groups seal platoons and
seal troops that have raw talent and
ammo for sure and then they'll have kind
of a guy come in that's a tyrant and an
egomaniac and that will permeate into
everybody mm-hmm the same way as you
know the one all I see that you're
talking about that that I've worked
around everywhere that guy goes he lifts
everybody else everyone that's around
him becomes better by his example yeah
yep
any other mistakes or major mistakes you
know it just back to being a when I was
a a troop senior enlisted advisor over
in Afghanistan and we were doing the
remain over day operations and there
were a lot of my younger guys that
didn't understand why we weren't going
why we weren't just going in hitting a
target and coming out during the same
cycle of darkness they felt like that
would be more effective and instead of
sitting down with them and explaining to
them why we were doing what we were
doing I would just tell them shut up and
get out there and you know hindsight not
not the right thing to do because then
they really don't know why they're doing
what they're doing and then there's
there's resentment that's building and
then they're just not going to be the
most effective at what they've got going
on yeah man I wish we could do this
whole job over again we kind of can
though I mean it goes back to the
resentment thing and in another bad R
word is that regret yeah I've learned
like all these dang mistakes I've made
and every big setback that I've
experienced in my life I feel like it's
kind of set me up for success through
moving forward so it's kind of like
glacier you know I'm every time I've
taken like a foot back I then move
forward yeah three feet yeah learn from
it and press on what's interesting for
me is as I look back at my career now
and I was actually doing this when I was
thinking about mistakes man and I was
actually talking to you
Dave Burke the deal Dave yeah and like
all the things that I talk about all the
time now I did those things like when I
was a platoon commander I was doing this
stuff I wasn't I wasn't as crystallized
but like when I was it's asking a
greater boom I was dude this is what I
was doing but this is what I was doing
it wasn't like I had it crystallized it
was like I had this like oh this is what
I had seen enough and most of it I'd
seen as you just said through modeling
from some good officers and from some
bad officers and some good chiefs and
some bad Chiefs where I'd say oh that's
what that I'm gonna hey why does that
guy do that he always tells me what's
gonna okay I'm gonna always do that you
know like that kind of thing it's but
but like you said we when you get done
with a job you look at me like man let
me just do that one more time
because I will knock this thing out of
the park so when is the moment do you
think for you that you're the collective
light bulb went off and you kind of put
a lot of this together the collective
well that you know the first FTX is a
trade it when you got there and that was
a part of it like I like my assistant
platoon commander in my oh I see I was
telling him this stuff you know I was
like hey man here's what's going on like
hey we needed to do this
hey you when you go in and briefed this
guy you need to be like this this stuff
I was doing it but then the next
deployment it was like when I was you
know when I was working with Lafe and
Seth mm-hmm you know it was me saying
hey man come here and I you know those
guys were whip out the freaking uh the
wheel books you know like after they
realized what was going on which was
like three days and to our our tasking
it and be like hey check this out boom
take it out and it right and they break
down like okay this is what okay got it
yes that makes sense and but as far as
actually taking it and crystallizing
nails absolutely my first the first FTX
I went on with trade that and watch that
watch the tasking out there just fall
apart and and and all I was doing was
sitting there thinking if this was my
task unit number one here's what
be doing and number two when I got back
I'd be telling the platoon commander
this this and this I'd be telling those
guys hey this is where you screwed up
and I just was watching it and go okay I
years I basically condensed everything
that I had told my guys and said okay
here's what you guys need to do and that
was cover move simple prioritize next
you can do centralized command they
answers to so many the answers to all
problems boil down to four things and
they all kind of overlap
yeah they definitely are intertwined
they overlap and you do have to throw
extreme ownership on there only because
if you don't take ownership of the
problems then they're not gonna get
solved and that is gonna hurt you so
yeah dad at the muster JP was saying
some stuff that really stuck with me and
he set it out at the at the PT and he's
like hey everybody we get to be here
this is an opportunity that you have to
be here and he said that and I thought
man that is just an awesome perspective
to have I called him up yesterday I'm
like hey I want to talk about this and
you know just fill me in on what your
mindset is and he goes yeah he goes you
know what because because when he was at
Budds the way he looked at a four-mile
time run which I hated for model time
runs I just I'm throw up every four mile
time run his his attitude was I get to
do this four mile time run so if you
take that and you start applying that to
everything heck yeah they just don't
have there's no room to [__] about a
damn thing you know I moved through the
airport today and I see a guy with no
legs and I'm like man my life is so good
both my legs work and and I shouldn't I
shouldn't have a complaint in the world
one of the one of the last thing and
we're getting kind of like getting
pretty long here but um you know one of
the things I worked I wanted you to talk
about and I know this isn't really old I
guess it is because it has a leader of
your family
I know that we we have to we have to
lead our family right
and one of you you you posted something
the other day that was before legit I
think was called a promise to my
daughter and I was I just asked if you
could bring it in because I think if if
you don't mind reading that to everyone
I think it's a pretty cool setup of how
to take ownership of of your family and
how to how what you what you as a leader
and as a dad and as a father and as a
husband what you are putting forth as
your goal as your objective as your
strategy with your daughter and I
thought it was pretty awesome so if you
wouldn't mind reading that that'd be
cool
absolutely a promise to my daughter I
will love you always unconditionally no
matter what I will not pamper you
this will Forge your resilience that
will help you conquer all of life's
obstacles I do not entail intend to
raise a princess but rather a warrior
with fire in her heart and ice in her
veins in my mind there is nothing you
can't do no job or goal beyond your
reach
I will challenge you so that you stand
confidently on your own two feet and I
will set the example on how to treat
those you love so that when you choose a
partner it will be someone that lifts
you up I will invest my time and energy
in you so that when I am gone enough
memories of me will be with you in your
heart to keep forever stand tall with
your shoulders back this world is yours
for the taking
yeah that's awesome man and obviously I
would think the same stuff for my son
yeah yeah but well you'll have to write
one a little bit specific to him very
similar yeah no that's awesome and that
that's really cooling them better a lot
of people will a listen to it and be
plagiarise it and you know
ab-absolutely yeah for their own family
but no that's awesome man and um like I
said we're we're going pretty long right
now so that that's a good place to wrap
up this one what is this now we've done
something like seven or eight hours
seven or eight hours awesome so echo
speaking of having a strategy to get to
where we want to go to be a little bit
better across the board in all aspects
what do you got for us got some tips oh
by the way yeah I read that on Instagram
if I'm not mistaken and I considered
plagiarizing it please my daughter now I
got the confirmation or what do you guys
call it cleared hot yeah all right there
you go
and you were right about the the to face
things when you said let me guess what
you're gonna say oh you're absolutely
100% correct cool yeah like act one way
hey boss a you know hate something
didn't a your awesome y'all said then
right when he leaves then you know yeah
you see that guy yeah good do that
alcohol last yes we're on the path okay
good
straight the strategic versus a tact
tactical long game short game I know
you've been in the wrong game three
pictures small picture all the same
thing when people ask echo what's like
the big takeaway I think that's its
primary takeaway is focusing on the long
game which he's a football so you know
he like thinks the game thing
Super Mario Brothers sir as well more
propitious but you know as opposed to
thinking short cape
yeah that if you look at your life
everyday in long game slash strategic
instead of short game slash tactical we
could end up in a better spot yeah
and when I say the biggest I mean that's
the one that applies to like though my
whole life there's other stuff no
complaining now and was a that's a big
one no complaining no uh blaming of
course and then um present I never
really had the reason faint the jealousy
thing a that's something I've never
really had a non-event why yeah balance
me always felt obvious when I when I
when I discovered like anger like when
you're mad that's like something up with
you kind of thing you know it's natural
it is oh when I love that's one of the
biggest one of the biggest things I got
from doing this podcast is Captain plum
saying when they were in the in the
Hanoi Hilton yeah yeah and him saying if
you were annoyed with your prison bunk
mate
yeah it was your fault yeah I was like
hit me like a diamond bullet yeah right
between the aisles that was extreme
ownership next level cuz I always
annoyed with that other person you oh no
actually you know what that's my fault
yeah yeah that was good when I when I
discovered it was a book I was reading
called mind games I mentioned it before
and it said small little passage said
basically um in a nutshell like when you
have anger issues not to say when you
get mad but just as if you have anger
issues it has something to do with your
self esteem like you have low self
esteem and that hit me really hard like
oh man that hit me so hard that I was
like man I can never get mad ever again
that's that's like a reverse psychology
on your ego because your ego is not
gonna turn myself in because low
self-esteem here
oh yes genius same thing with the
drinking now you you you put it into
words good where it K so drinking right
I ended up figuring out or it being
revealed to me that Dre like when you
drink when you have a drink you want
another one
and you want another one and your mind
and the more you have the more you sort
of want you can't really stop or
whatever you don't want to stop it's
just your brain tricking you you know
it's your brain tricky like your brain
is chemically saying oh we need this hey
we need this you know we need more
whatever the filler you were getting
manipulated it felt like I was a sucker
as you said and like he wasn't whoa whoa
whoa I'm not a sucker I don't care if
it's my own brain I'm not a sucker or
whatever and it was just that easy meant
and that easy to control it but yes it
is a reverse psychology on your ego good
as opposed to regular psychology on your
evil short term and long term
jujitsu right yeah it's really used to
rip the word reverse reversal London I
thought such you're gonna handle the
transition negative negative I'm saying
I'm on the first long game and short
game jujitsu is one of those long game
short game situations 100% part of the
path part of the many activities that
were all doing on the path Jason Gardner
got into good shape obviously
so we're exercising we're doing jujitsu
we're eating healthy we're not getting
mad at people we're not showing
resentment we're not complaining
mmm-hmm various other things so we'll go
over anyway jiu-jitsu when you dude you
just so you could Anita geet what key do
we get origin you get it from origin
main comm this is where all their stuff
by the way is made all in America from
the cotton they grow from the ground all
the way to the end from the dirt to the
shirt sure yeah all that you know or gin
main calm all seasons yes American
American oh yeah yes which we are
producing right now we are hiring more
people to produce even more so my
apologies on it if you're ordering right
now maybe we don't have your size we're
working it we're working it hard we're
growing yeah
those good some people I appreciate that
they have the 28 inch inseam there you
go commentating everybody yeah there's a
few guys at the muster who had them on
how's it comin
that's good I don't have any but hey
those are the breaks and that's just the
life I live also
if sweat pants and shirts and whatnot
other stuff on there it's also
supplements supplements the best kind of
supplements by the way yeah there was
some there were some people freaking out
on the strawberries they every tried
strawberry slavery yeah yeah this is
just not me
oh you don't monster I'm not not that
kind of strawberry guy I definitely got
so I'm gonna try it it didn't work I'm
on the hardcore mint chocolate chip and
then the vanilla for me yeah yeah you
get that vanilla gorilla and throw it
inside your coffee your coffee heck yeah
that's your sweetener kind of that's
your like my trimmer yeah
boom yeah those good meth in and then
that's irises mixing that and when you
drink that in the morning Oh what time
like right at right after I PT and then
how when do you feel hungry for your
next meal oh I don't eat until like 1:00
1:00 or 2:00 o'clock yeah just that and
iris is just putting into everything
she's making mommy
yeah she's making notebooks and
smoothies and all that stuff so we go
through quite a bit of MalK in our house
you know and the kids love it yeah that
strawberry can make like a it's like a
milkshake smoothie mmm hybrid here's
what I said the other day if you put in
front of me
Haagen Dazs strawberry milkshake yes
right sure Nestle's strawberry Quik yes
and strawberry Slayer milk and I was
gonna die in 15 minutes so we're just
going pure satisfaction so you're in a
short-term like if this long game is out
of the picture yes I'm going straight to
the strawberries their milk because
that's what tastes the best that is the
taste test right no one does it taste
test like that I'm not throwing a caveat
on there but the haagen-dazs is gonna be
sugary or the Nestle's Quik is gonna
give you a sugar no we're taking the
long game totally other picture we're
going up here short-term tactical taste
where you at
strawberry Slayer breaketh
the names awesome - yes yeah well you
know okay also join Pete was trying to
like tell me product names he's like
he's like brave someone Pecos
you know Pete's like mr. creative yes
right yes I get creative that he even
told me yeah oh yeah he'll tell you it's
like that's his creative stuff right so
pizza hit me up he says so he said
upsetting me all these all these things
strawberry sniper I'll have to pull out
the listed so far everything is brand of
military terms but yeah don't catch Pete
he gets into these moods creativity is
just coming out of his coming out of his
brain and he'll start hitting me up with
texts about strawberry sniper yeah I'm
not I'm not that man it's wrong that man
he had someone's butt Slayer is better
I'm used to Slayer someone here sniper
I'm like oh I see why that was like a
distance that you know whatever I think
of some of the other wack ones you can't
just because sorry's people yeah some of
them were real funny actually I texted
him he texted Brian and me he's Texas
all these names and I was like okay stop
no Jorge just started laughing yeah so
check that you know he's probably had a
hear probably a little too much
discipline go yeah
potentially yeah yeah how many
discipline go are you on right now for
daily no per day yeah it's just because
I had to get up at 3:00 a.m. oh right
now when did you go to bed at what 10:10
p.m. soon you're on five hours asleep
ready did you sleep on the plane
no can you sleep on planes yes I can see
sometimes I can but I was I was just
writing all these notes in you're ready
for this and some sometimes I can just
turn it off but I wasn't able to sleep
on the point I can sleep on planes not
as well as echo though echo gets the
world championship belt we're secret
plans we get on a plane I got a plane
with him within within 38 seconds he's
asleep but he looks and he puts his
sunglasses on he looks like he's awake
so yeah so discipline go that's a good
situation I take two every morning check
so get up in the morning to discipline
go and then joint warfare you takin
morning and night yeah and I noticed how
many do you take I'm taking two in the
morning and two at night and then what's
your body weight right now 160 something
like I take three I take three join
warfare 3 curl oil
morning 3 don't work for three krill oil
night if I'm if I got a little little
situation going on I might if I'm around
I'll take three during the day for the
lunch time two days you got the infusion
infusion that your infusion it's good
man so that's that yeah don't forget
about the warrior kid milk - yeah for
the warrior kids yeah well so all right
well let's let's talk about it then
what's what in your opinion or a kid
milk strawberry or strawberry Slayer
strawberry Slayers thicker it's like
yeah I don't think it actually I think
the way that they are they are actually
suitable for their audience so that's
this strawberry the warrior kids
strawberry milk is just a little bit a
little bit lighter will say because it
does have less protein and the one they
don't want is a little bit heavier guns
a little bit more like that haagen-dazs
hitters like that where you have feel
Vaughn with that hitter oh also chuckle
white tea yes very refresh a the light
the nice stuff about it very refreshing
certified organic pomegranate white tea
doesn't sound hardcore but it can a few
deadlifting eight thousand pounds that
is kind of hardcore yeah proven by the
way Jason gardener scientifically yeah
you know all about that I'm talking
about 100% guaranteed can I get sued for
that you know maybe I guess if there was
someone that couldn't hit a 10,000 pound
deadly yeah then they might come at me
yeah come at me bro yeah I'll say lift
harder amen drink more you can't yeah
you got a train because there's no way
everyone else is dead lifting 8,000
what's wrong with you a guy yeah yeah
yeah it makes sense
also we have a store it's called Jocko
store I think we all know that this is
where you can get rash guards t-shirts
I'm gonna represent discipline equals
freedom
truckers hats beanies some beanies there
man I gotta refill the beanies oh so
maybe you don't have what well current
welco never wears hats so these
apparently uh no on the pro have you
even even had a cold head before yeah I
had a cold hit before sure well depends
on what you mean by cold but you know
yeah you put it on you know put that
lightly on her the coldness on the head
and then right when you shave it like
with the woody called a brazier no we're
gonna be great and I think when you bake
your head that's what that's an
expression oh yeah I can get a little
nippy I guess kind of cold well anyways
the rest of us would like some more
beanies online yes sir you got it and
for the summertime
yes sir doesn't know if you're up in
Maine in the summertime yeah or you're
up in Michigan in the summertime yeah or
you're up in Washington in the
summertime once the Sun Goes Down yeah
you can get that little chilly yeah yeah
but at you yeah I agree and the thought
is here too in my opinion and you might
as well have a beanie that says
discipline equals freedom yeah men
represent with everything also the
hoodies like I mentioned lightweight
hoodies lightweight hoodies
Jason I saw you yelling at the muster I
look good right not bad
well thank you oh now we don't know how
everyone looks well well it's part of
the game it can be part of maybe not for
you aesthetics wise right we got
functionality we have aesthetics they're
not exclusive yeah and you remember I
was asking you about the heavy weights
cuz that's what I but that's what I need
up in northeastern Washington Canadian
border we all work functionally York we
are working currently at this time so
that by the time fall walls rolls around
we offer the heaviest of heavy weight
hoodies yeah that's the plan yes I'm
talking big time the real deal yeah yeah
where there'll be no doubt in your mind
you like oh yeah this is this is the
heaviest sodium ever heard that putting
on five pounds yeah that's what we want
to leave but aesthetics huh
let's say an a factor of ten is function
answer this question you need you need
level two in functionality
obviously aesthetics what are we what do
you at what number a seven that's pretty
significant
what do you at zero zero straight-up
zero my delight
it's the lightweight any anything having
to do with fashion I think I think
you're at a one that's what I think ya
know if there are some things where I'd
be like this looks stupid
therefore I will not wear it yeah so
that we are correct that puts me on a
level one all right well how about this
you got ego three to four t-shirts mmm
one green mm-hmm like green green not OD
green
mmm green green one red one black mmm
one purple which one you choosing black
Y looks better right doesn't get dirty
it's easy boy anyway stuff on there too
is jock ghost or calm this is we can get
stuff to represent yeah check it out
like something get something did you say
origin main calm yes okay that's for yes
for the word somebody I want somebody
that strawberry and of course yes
also subscribers layers should have like
a like a like a theme like when you say
it it should be like in the background
you go to strawberry so that you're got
a double bass drum the hammer dukka
dukka dukka dukka yes railing yeah I
don't know if I agree with that but you
know is a good name for sure also
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already on iTunes and wherever you get
your podcasts and don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast yes which comes out
not as frequently as it should it should
step up this summer as time opens up to
create and record that particular
podcast yeah thank you
and and then you can get some of that
warrior kid so you're friends with Matt
right mmhmm yeah up there Aiden making
it on his farm Irish Oaks yeah Irish so
Transcom how do you know him
through iris he come to your farm yeah
we were gonna buy meat from him then
when he came to deliver it to you he
swung by and visited us I've always gone
that day so I didn't meet him but him
and I have chatted on the phone a whole
bunch of times awesome
yeah he's a firefighter up and up at
Jericho me and he's got a farm as well
and his son Aiden was a young warrior
kid makes soap so that everyone in the
world can stay clean yep cool
that's good soap too but only a hunk
tional soap it's not the decorative you
know the ones that you know nice makes
and it's like here it's not you're not
even supposed to really use it yeah the
decoration of a gift if you will yes
also we have a youtube channel the
Chocolate castor YouTube channel is
where you can get the video version of
course there and see what Jason looks
like right handsome I'd say no Jocko it
you know what just take it easy
amen either way if you are interested in
that we have a youtube channel also some
excerpts on there you know we'll cut up
little excerpts and sometimes Eko puts
cello music behind them and you push
explosions in them yeah sometimes when I
want to enhance them maybe maybe like a
certain message that you talk about hits
me hard
I say hey let me express this you know
put some stuff on do you ever feel like
maybe we should just get it a couple of
cello players in here no I don't I don't
ever feel like that at all and you know
I think we should stick with what we're
doing that's my opinion
here's the thing about YouTube though as
far as uh subscribing yeah so it doesn't
even matter and you might notice JD do
you spend time on YouTube yes like okay
so here's what I learned and observed if
you subscribe to someone on YouTube it
doesn't matter that much like their
stuff won't show up all the time oh I
like how you would expect you'd think
like oh if you subscribe their stuff is
gonna sort of show up on your what do
you call it the home yeah page or
whatever doesn't so much to do that and
when I get an email every time you post
something new okay now yeah now you're
talking because when you subscribe to
someone and you do that additional step
you click on the little bell I think
it's like right next to or on the
subscribe button or wherever it is right
there if you do
then you'll get the alert email no my
lord ever my alerts actually come onto
my phone they like spring up fun debt
from you to before your Jean oh podcast
just posted a new video that's from my
from the app from the YouTube app from
the YouTube app yes which is pretty cool
yeah yeah so if you want that this is
what I'm saying so when you subscribe
it's almost like a half subscribe not
even a half so it's like a quarter
subscribed that's what it is cuz you're
sort of like oh yeah I officially sort
of subscribe but YouTube's like cool
okay I think we're not gonna let you
know we gotta subscribe this is way
different this is different I'm saying
if you want to subscribe and you want to
get alerts and you want it to sort of be
in your what do you call it the feet or
whatever you get a little bell this is
what I learned about I'm worried about
since you're very decentralized since
there's a lot of decentralized command
here yes I'm worried that if people
don't subscribe all of a sudden you're
just gonna start putting the little
thing at the end of your enhanced videos
that says that says like she reads click
Subscribe make sure it's like it shows
the little finger click subscriber and
if that happens no we're gonna have a
problem yes sir the videos make it very
centralized real quick real quick well
we're not gonna worry about that because
I agree with you 100% like share
subscribe yeah yeah before you watch
this video go down to the pub and click
subscribe now I'm sure this slightly
annoying I hate it when I see that yeah
I'm sure there's some function yes
that's the island of when you meet
someone like what's the equivalent of a
human interaction where you say that we
are money drop in the ass bomb would it
be likely I'll that but it would be like
like hey good to meet you can I have a
pat on the back please like isn't that
basically what it is that's the human
interaction equivalent yeah okay nice to
meet you um give me your phone and I'm
gonna index I'm gonna put my yeah my
phone are in there yeah so I can text
you what I'm doing yeah all the time
yeah give me a pat on the back all right
sorry I know I might think that that's
actually a good little an analogical
annelotte analogy um like comparison
tasks
to find the analogies what I'm saying
psychological warfare itunes google play
mp3 platforms if you want it if if you
want to wake up call yes which a lot of
people say can't you make an alarm can't
you make an alarm can't you make an
alarm yes you can use psychological
warfare as an alarm there's a bunch of
alarm options there there's also
something on there if you're if you're
feeling like you want to eat a doughnut
or you want to eat a bag of Cheetos yeah
once last time you ate a bag of Cheetos
one time I ate a whole bag of Hershey's
Kisses and this is when I was in the
team's I'm talking to a grown man how
big was the bag like a like a good size
like the size of a book the size of a
regular-sized book like was one of those
yeah it was like six years ago my mom
came over to my house and put a whole
bag of candy corn it was around
Halloween and every time I walk by it
out with stuff things in my mouth and
pretty soon they are all gone they're
they're good at cents I bet I couldn't
eat one right now because I you know
kind of cut sweet stuff out and every
time I slip I taste something I'm like
holy cow the thing I noticed that is
with with coca-cola Oh like I can't even
can't even come close to drinking a
coca-cola I mean I haven't had one legit
like hey I'm gonna have a Coke in
probably 10 or 15 years or something
about a long time even longer than that
but when I when I look at him or like
the last time I tried to sip when I was
like yeah they're like syrup yeah so
anyways yeah like to see that like you
didn't cook though so that psychological
warfare you can get that on any of those
platforms also flipside canvas comp if
you want the visual reminder or
something my brother
Dakota Meyer has a company called flip
side campus.com and he's making all
kinds of cool stuff he's about to run
out some more your kids stuff to some
little warrior kid about like his teddy
roosevelt's definitely he's good after
it yeah so he's making some really cool
stuff art all right with layers art with
layers there you go
I like that also on it expanding your
home gym you getting more kettlebells
which I did by the way Darth Vader cowl
much away 7d ok here's the thing about
The 70-pound like sure I'm not
you know I'm gonna be more impressed
with your hundred pound kettlebell that
you were whatever bragging to me about
there you go there you go 106 but the 70
and the 72 the gorilla won or whatever
those in my opinion have the most like
play university yes yeah yes yeah those
are great I agree yeah plus the Darth
Vader I mean come on man
it's the ultimate one I think okay I
should they should have made the old
they should have made the Darth Vader
like a hundred at least over a hundred
pounds yeah in my opinion Jason you're
the Star Wars expert yeah he should
definitely be the heaviest who's the
most who's the most powerful character
in Star Wars Darth Vader doesn't seem
like he's kind of a chump some no
negative nah you'd think the Emperor may
be but it's Darth Vader Darth Vader dude
your mash is that Burke you're about to
die what do you think yeah I mean I
don't know you know Darth Maul was
pretty dang badass you know what I mean
he's like the guy that chopped up pretty
quick but I mean Darth Vader lost Darth
Vader lost to Luke Skywalker who
crumbled immediately by the way you know
later on Darth Vader man I think it's
Darth Vader yeah I like Vader mmm-hmm
the real leader lifts people up you ever
see I mean and Darth Vader's holding but
Darth Vader went through the whole arc
he was good bad good boom you know I
don't think you know well I'm sure the
Dolph song unless yes I got that
kettlebell there's a lot of good stuff
there's these there's these electrolyte
minerals that are part of my daily daily
manga meetings with the discipline
nonetheless Khan there are Netcom slash
Jaco
and check out some stuff on there some
really good stuff yeah all right some
books weigh the warrior Kid 3 the book
is called where there's a will there is
a good message talking about it already
check that one out it is available now
also where the warrior Kid one end to
Mark's mission is to number one is way
of the warrior kid
check those out for your kid to teach
your kid these lessons these lessons
that Jason I just talked about for two
plus hours are broken down simplified
and and sprinkled sprinkled throughout
these books so that your kid is gonna
read them and your kid is gonna save
things to you like dad I think your that
might be your ego talking so that the
idea of ego gets introduced in way the
warrior kid 3 as where it gets
introduced for the first time so why
because I wish somebody would have told
me about my ego I wish somebody would
have explained to me that I was
resentful I was jealous I was I was
whining no one did hmm or if my dad did
I didn't listen because I was a young
punk so get those books also if you got
a younger kid you can get Mikey in the
Dragons as well which again this is the
thing where your kid gets taught a
lesson
hey I didn't listen to my dad my I
didn't listen to my mom Jason didn't
listen to his mom Jason didn't listen
his dad I've been sitting around with a
bunch of like real really squared away
people business people and we start
talking about kids and and then I said
hey wait a second who here listen to
their parents no one raises their hands
like very few there's the one occasional
to occasional any Haskell's yeah yeah I
always listen - no you didn't liar
most mostly but you what happens is when
they hear it from another angle they
listen to and they go okay I understand
that and they think it's cool it's Uncle
Jake say it it's not my dad because your
parent your kids want to rebel against
you because they know they have to leave
the nest so they got to set up some kind
of a barrier so they need someone to
give them advice but that's someone be
Uncle Jake let that someone be the king
in Mikey and the Dragons so there you go
that's that
also we got obviously disciplinary to
the Field Manual if you're an adult you
need to know how to get on the path and
stay on the path get that book and put
it by your bedside and read that read a
page in the morning have you ever had a
book that will get you out of bed No
okay discipline equals freedom feel man
who put it next to your bed yeah yeah
you'll be like I'm getting out of bed
I'm gonna go get some help
then there's extreme ownership in that I
gotta be a leadership piece of books
about leadership written by me and my
brother life babban about the lessons
that we learned overseas now you can
apply them in your team in your business
in your life also we got a tional on
front leadership consultancy and we're
very busy you know why we're very busy
we're very busy because no matter what
problem you have in your team in your
business the problem is a leadership
problem if you want to get it solved you
got to solve the leadership the
leadership problems that you have and if
you can do that then they're solve the
problems in your company so it's me it
slave babban JP Danelle Dave Burke Flynn
Cochran Mike Sorelli Mike bimah and
Jason Gardner if you want us to help you
go to a salon front comm for details we
got the muster Chicago has done did it
sell out
yes it did how did you like the most was
your first monster Jason how do you like
it Wow
it was amazing don't you wish you got to
go to that when you were 25 years old
yeah years old
I was super impressed by a there are
people that had their kids there yeah
yeah that's not normal right
yeah I mean when you say there was
people there was probably okay and by my
kids there were I'm talking about one 13
year old that was there but there was a
quite a few like teenagers and in high
school yeah I would say 16 to 21
there'll be a good amount maybe a dozen
yeah right and then but the other was
one 13 year old the warrior cat that was
just straight getting after it yeah that
he was not early more
peaty way doing it you dimension that
warrior kid rash guard yeah if you want
to get that there's anyways that's the
muster they always sell out the next one
is in Denver its 19th and 20th of
September and it's gonna settle out
Sydney Australia December 4th and 5th
it's gonna sell out we got people in
Australia yes we do when I went to
Brizzy there was people from all over
Australia coming to hang out oh yeah
home of david hackworth brisbane that's
really moved take it yeah and if you
want to come to that co2 extreme
ownership calm get on it early EF online
if you can't come to the muster or you
can't bring your entire company the
muster because the muster is expensive
then get go to EF online.com and what
that is it's leadership training but the
thing is leadership training is not an
inoculation you can't just go to leaders
you're training one time and then you're
like oh cool i got extreme ownership now
i'm good to go it doesn't work like that
just like you can go to one jiu-jitsu
class or even one week's worth of
jiu-jitsu class you can't go to a
two-day jiu-jitsu Semler now you're good
to go no you need to keep training and
that's what happens here as well so
you'll be it's not it's not an
inoculation you got to get it repeatedly
and that's what EF online does or if you
can't make it to the muster mmm
go to UF online.com and also EF
overwatch taking proven leaders from
SpecOps and combat aviation and putting
them in companies in the civilian sector
that need leaders now you might think
well they don't have any experience in
my industry cool they'll learn it that's
what we do
hire for their character hire for their
leadership capability and then teach
them the industry specifics they'll pick
up and they will fill in the leadership
holes that are causing you problems and
if you want to hear more about 90's TV
shows or super mario brothers from eka
or you want to hear more about war or
leadership from Jason or me then all of
us are on the interwebs Jason is on
Instagram
Jason dot n dot Gardner he's on Twitter
Jason n Gardner he's on Facebook as well
Jason Gardner and obviously echo and I
are both on those platforms Twitter
Instagram and ha echoes on Echo Charles
and I am at Jaco Willick and thanks to
all the veterans out there like Jason
who did their time on the line and
thanks to everyone else out there right
now in the fight thanks for protecting
our way of life you got any other
closing costs nothing for the group
check and also thanks to police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers Border
Patrol Secret Service and all the first
responders
thank you all for keeping us safe here
at home and remember that we all make
mistakes but the mistakes that you can't
recover from are the ones that you don't
own the ones that you don't admit so
step up admit your mistakes and own your
mistakes and then no matter what keep
getting after it and until next time
this is Jason gardener and echo and
Jocko out